so that uh
ufo report came out they said they
couldn't really explain anything
and a lot of people think it's a dud so
we've been talking about a lot of other
stuff i mean you got tucker carlson
saying he's being spied on by the nsa i
mean that's a huge story the bite
administration
and uh we're sitting here and we're
being joined by candace owens
and we're just having this crazy
conversation about the mandela effect
and time travel and ufos and i'm like
you know what
like what candace mentions we just talk
about ufos
and i'm like we could certainly talk
politics but haven't
you talked about politics all the time
all the time let's talk a lot about the
weird stuff because there's actually
some weird stuff and this is still
breaking news this pentagon report so i
guess uh
she's gonna roll with it and just have a
conversation about whatever yeah
time travel mandela effect everything
shazam the movie with same bed that
didn't exist but you insist it did
it did it definitely existed yeah i mean
you're so right everyone always
pigeonholes me and it's like let's talk
about politics it's like yeah i love
policy let's talk about it but there's a
lot more interesting stuff and politics
is related to everything i mean
ufos obviously because they've been
stealing these reports
and i was saying to you offline that my
grandmother my maternal grandmother
swore until her dying day from the time
that we were young
that she was walking down the street and
she saw a crashed ufo
and a little green man came out and our
whole lives of my entire life she died
in 2013 or 2012.
i just thought she was crazy you know i
thought she was absolutely nuts
i was like this like obviously this
didn't happen because aliens aren't real
um and then it's been interesting now to
see them come out and say oh yeah these
ufos are real and
just think about how many people lived
and saw
ufos crop circles whatever you want to
call it
and were told that they were crazy and
the government called them conspiracy
theorists and called them tin foil hat
heads and now
some of them many of them dead like my
grandmother there's no redemption for
that it's just like
the government allowed entire swaths of
the population to be gaslit
as opposed to just saying yeah
something's going on but we we can't
tell you anything
and then you have to apply that logic to
today so now
who what are they who are they calling
the conspiracy theorists like is this
gonna be like you know
40 years from now the craziest
conspiracy theorists that we hear now
and they're gonna be like oh yeah
actually that's true classified
the report saying they can't explain it
so it's basically now the what one big
conspiracy all these ufos we don't know
what they are someone's doing something
yeah so it sounds like sounds like they
there was a conspiracy and they've
admitted it yeah and they've known
they've known they've known for a very
long time
and then you know we'll just talk about
interdimensional aliens and uh but
interestingly there is this funny thing
that's popped up where general mark
milly who's
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
right now told uh i think it was an rotc
class they'd be fighting hybrid armies
and little green men
and so naturally with the ufo report
coming out this clip is resurfacing
where everyone's like oh
this proves it and there's like an
article from i think it's from like
army.com or something like no
he's speaking metaphorically but we'll
we'll talk about that we'll get in all
that we also have uh
ian hanging out yes your favorite
psychonaut in the house thank you tim um
i'm gonna tell them what you just asked
me right before we went live
um do you like a lot do you like
psychedelics no you said
are you on twitter you do have twitter
right
yeah it turns out the real candice so i
just thought thanks
i want that's how you know like the most
humbling thing when anderson goes are
you on twitter what's up homie
let's hang out like we're 12 again we
all bust it out
dude there's this thing called walking
plasma balls that i've just been reading
about where apparently they triangulate
lasers from like base stations and they
hit an area in the sky
and then they cause what looks like a
ball of plasma that reads on radar
and so a lot of these things that people
think they're catching on radar their
ufos are actually this
focused energy and now we're talking
like can they do it from space stations
can they triangulate lasers from outer
space to make us
and they keep doing it over these
military bases but there's probably
something else to like actual craft that
people can get in and out of
well we'll get into all of that for sure
yeah yes we got lady chuck
i am super excited about this
conversation because i don't think that
i
have ever heard candace talking about
aliens
and i'm excited to get you out of uh get
her out of like her
corner so we'll see what she has to say
yes i'm stoked but before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
we will have a bonus segment coming up
it usually goes live around
it gets uploaded around 11 pm and uh
that'll be fun we talk about things that
youtube basically bans you for and we
all know how the game is played so
be a member there we just hired a couple
more people for the newsroom which we'll
be launching in a couple of weeks with
your support
we're actually going to be launching a
new podcast too talking about weird
crazy conspiracies we've been talking
about this for a long time we hired
a really great guy who put up an amazing
article you're gonna have to check it
out if you want to see more
but we have a bunch of crazy stories
there's like birds falling from the sky
and disappearing and of course it does
overlap with a lot of the military news
we've got like marco rubio coming out
this was a few weeks ago saying these
these ufos whatever they are they're a
threat to our national security they fly
above our military bases
so there's a breaking news element and
an unsolved mysteries element so we're
gonna talk all about that again go to
timcast.com be a member but don't forget
to like share subscribe
uh share the show with your friends and
let's just uh jump into this news
so you guys may have seen it this uh
this ufo report we've all
been waiting for it and a lot of people
said it was a dud pentagon report says
ufos can't be explained and this
admission is a big deal
it is a big deal it means they're coming
up right now and saying oh yeah you know
all those ufos people reported seeing
well they are real we've seen them too
and we have no idea what they are
so now it's just opened up the door to
everybody kind of being like
something is happening we don't know
what should we be scared
i want to just quickly clarify i said
walking plasma balls are called talking
plasma balls
and i think that might be part of what
these people are seeing so wait wait
what is that it's when you focus lasers
from like at least three or more
base stations into a point in the air
and then it creates like a ball of
plasma that reads
on radar and they think that it's a
craft because they can move it around
really fast and they're like no craft
can move at this speed because they're
just
pointing a light but do you think our
military wouldn't know that
if they yeah they might know it it's
crazy it's almost i think their gas
is gaslighting the right word i think
that they're they're prepping us for
some sort of like military they want us
to fund the military fund the military
be afraid
oh interesting that's a very good
perspective but then it doesn't explain
why so many people
for so many years especially after world
war ii started saying that they were
seeing
you know spacecrafts and seeing things
in the middle of the night especially
i i am the most amazed by crop circles
like this is like inexplicable like
perfect measurements
circles you know a bit hit in the middle
of nowhere in the middle of the night
couldn't possibly say oh it's just a
prank and they cover it up i mean it's
just been a lot of questions
and the government never answers it you
know and i i definitely of course
there's always
some sort of initiative to get more
money from
its citizens but i've always just
thought that they know a lot more than
they're ever telling us of course
because they're the government
and it's too much when it happens all
over the world it stops being conspiracy
right so it's one thing to say
okay my grandmother saw this thing alien
spacecraft and she said a green man came
out and you could be like all right
whatever your grandmother is probably
crazy
cool but there was also a story and this
one is
to me the most striking and you can fact
check me on the country i'm pretty sure
it's zimbabwe
um but there was like 51 school children
that were playing on the playground and
they all ran inside
and they said they were crying and they
were terrified and their teachers were
inside correcting work i think it was 65
exactly 65 school children and they all
said they described a spacecraft that
landed
and this was almost like 30 years ago um
and that a little person came out and
was looking at them but didn't say
anything but they knew what the person
was saying or the
alien whatever it was wanted them to
think in their heads they didn't need to
move their mouth
to communicate and so this happened and
obviously it
made a big splash around the world and
so harvard
actually flew in psychiatrists and
psychologists
into this random place in zimbabwe and
sat down with the kids to determine
whether or not this was a hoax
right and so they isolated the kids and
they spoke to each of the kids and you
can actually watch the interviews of
these
children so young and they all kind of
look terrified and
they describe what they saw and he had
them draw pictures and he's
interviewing them and asking them so how
did it make you feel you know
it made me feel scared you know they're
all talking about it and he concluded at
the end of it that there was no way that
this was a hoax because it's impossible
for that many children to lie
um and tell the same story and we all
know that like you know kids they just
like they don't have that kind of a
memory they're not nefarious they can't
all tell the same story
and the most interesting thing about
that despite harvard coming in into
africa including that they told the
truth is that now they're all adults
and they did an update interview with
them and they all say that's exactly
what happened on the day that's what
happened
you know in that school yard that day
and we don't have any explanation for it
other than
did you know that since the lockdowns
ufo sightings paranormal activity has
been
has been going up reports of people
saying unexplained things have been
happening yeah
it's it's weird i mean it's just weird
stuff and to me
you know on the topic of aliens i have
met people and they just like there's no
way it exists and
define alien okay just i mean any i
guess being that we're not aware of when
you say alien you don't have to say it
has to have big eyes or whatever
but i always found it really strange you
really have to apply a little bit of
common sense
that we're obviously not the most
intelligent being otherwise we would be
like you know hey
tim let's go to mars tomorrow real quick
you know grab something come back
let's go on you know just fly up and
look at all the planets and we can't do
that and not even that aliens could be
the bottom of the ocean right we can't
even get to the bottom of the ocean so
it to me it's weird that there are some
people that go it's just impossible
because the government hasn't told us or
we haven't seen it with our own two eyes
so we didn't even have cell phones my
dad had a beeper
when i was growing up and thinking about
how much tech has changed it's like
we're definitely not the smartest beings
but we're also definitively the most
arrogant beings because so many people
are convinced that we are the smartest
being so
i guess we get one point for being super
arrogant i i bet we're actually fairly
stupid
um what i mean by that is we can collect
data
we like we'll watch a rock roll on the
ground and go oh and then figure out how
to make a wheel
but that's like the lowest level of
figuring out how to invent something
right
so if we can assume that there's other
intelligent life in the universe
then they're intelligent the likelihood
that there is a more intelligent
species than us is probably animals some
of them
think about some of the instincts that
animals have like you know dogs i mean
just they they have powers and things
that we don't really comprehend
as human beings like so as again we are
definitively i'm not saying that dogs
are the smartest i guess you could say
well they don't live in houses and they
don't have air conditioning and all this
stuff okay sure
but they definitely have you know a
different sense than human beings have
and people don't explore that at all
which i've always found to be really
weird there are foxes that are like
tuned into the magnetic
uh compass of earth so they can like aim
magnetic north when they hunt
and then they'll like dive on their prey
that's under the snow
the incredible wolves i mean i love
animals learning about weird things that
animals can do i'm like they're almost
aliens
sharks can sense electromagnetic energy
with their nose i think
you you were mentioning your gra was
your grandma told the story about a
little green man or whatever
a lot of people probably think something
like that's really crazy but uh
let me pull up the story we've got a few
stories that are resurfacing now because
of this uh ufo report
these are legitimate sources this is
armytimes.com i assure you this is news
guard certified
92.5 out of 100. army chief talks
little green men and sets off you and
ufo enthusiasts
they claim there's an explanation for
this but here's the quote
they say this is mark milley who's now
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
you'll be dealing with terrorists you'll
be dealing with hybrid armies
you'll be dealing with little green men
you'll be dealing with tribes
you're going to be dealing with it all
and you're going to be dealing with it
simultaneously milly said
now of course he should say right wait
what was that did milly just say cadets
will be battling little green men
and then they go no no no they just mean
that there are some countries that have
people in the military who are small
and they wear green outfits so that's
what they mean by little green men
and hybrid didn't mean like human alien
hybrids
it it means something i don't know not
chimera yeah i mean
i think for a lot of people like they
just don't like to apply their brains at
all they just they're more comfortable
believing whatever it is they're told
right i mean just like i always say to
somebody it's like going back
100 years and trying to explain the
concept of a cell phone to a human being
like it just could never happen like you
can't just like pick up the phone and
call someone and like you know
and have them be on the other end no
matter where you are and what country i
mean like they're they just can't get
their minds around it until it's
physically in their hands
and so people's you know are just not
ready to
even think about it a lot of times and
i'm the exact opposite where like i want
to hear
everything because i don't i think you
it if anything else it challenges you to
think critically
right and it's such an important
exercise to constantly be
trying to bend your mind like a pretzel
right
yeah i love the idea of infinity trying
to just understand it
that was a really really good point
about cell phones though imagine going
to the 90s
and saying within you know
it's what iphone came out 2007. if you
said within 10 or so years
you will have a device that can record
videos take photos
you touch it to control it it can give
you access to the summation of human
knowledge
to a certain degree you can communicate
with other people you can make phone
calls on it they'd be like get out of
here
yeah in 10 in in 10 or 15 years
even even when regular cell phones came
out like the nokia candy bar
if you explained a modern you know like
galaxy 21 or whatever they'd be like no
way
we'll forget that like playing
playstation think about trying to
explain
electricity to people that were using
lanterns to like to light their homes
like when jd rockefeller and like
that we know how he garnered his wealth
you know like oh we got gasoline and now
we've got lanterns and this is going to
power your home imagine trying to
explain to those people
the concept of electricity power in the
world right they would think you were a
tin foil hat a conspiracy theorist and
you would be on the outskirts of society
because you're crazy and actually
interesting little historical tidbit
when um
who was it uh uh not jd rockefeller
the other one of the big guys warburg uh
electricity
it was thomas edison but who funded him
it was a bank uh
chase bank jp morgan yeah i'm like
couldn't couldn't guess jp morgan do you
know what happened with the first time
he
uh thomas edison lit you know the first
one that was ever lit with electricity
do you know whose home it was
no jp morgan's right so he invites a
small crowd of wealthy people to come in
um and he shows them they come in so
everything's obviously lit by lanterns
and he turns on his house
and they're like oh my gosh this is
amazing and do you wanna know what his
father said to him afterwards he said
this is crazy
this will never power the world don't
invest in this any further this is stuff
that belongs in the circus
does jp morgan's dad jp morgan's dad
it's the first the first showing of
electricity was in that house
right so it's just it's you have to
think about history to kind of consider
the present
and we still have these people that
think this could never happen
and and yet it takes the conspiracy
theorists
you know of their time to really push
the world forward
i think they'd say zeus shot lightning
bolts i think he had electricity
yeah right have you heard of the baghdad
battery it's this ancient battery it's a
clay pot you fill it with vinegar
and it has a an iron rod in it and then
you wrap it with copper wire and it
produces an electrical charge
and they make like 50 of them and line
them all up and connect them all to each
other and so like in the pyramids
there's no fire
marks because they didn't use fire to
light when they were in their building
apparently they used theoretically
hypothetically as electricity so light
they had big batteries there's a
hieroglyph of this guy holding this big
what looks like a tube of like an in
with like a filament in it and then like
a slave is like holding the battery
behind him or something
well that's actually funny because
there's this whole concept now i'm very
into mythology i got like you know greek
mythology and i think there's something
um eternal about the lessons that you
learn when you study mythology but
what's interesting is if you consider a
lot of mythology
and you think of them you know even if
you think of egyptian hero hieroglyphics
and stories they tell
the concepts of their aliens could
literally just be like a person from
2021.
have you ever watched targeting sg-1
which is crazy they would have been like
this person's a god
oh my gosh this person just made life
and if the person told them they were a
god
then it would reinforce it would
reinforce it you you you want to watch
target sg-1
yeah that's basically what it's about
yeah right so they find this portal that
can open up with different codes to a
bunch of different planets
and there's an alien race that was
claiming to be gods
and they just had better technology so
these people are like yeah
they're gods and they're just it's magic
it's it's technology i think about like
the angels and the demons from the bible
and how they could fly and had wings i
think they had hang gliders
[Laughter]
swooping in with their i don't know what
dropping dropping fire
a little or jedi flaming oil on people
and stuff yeah jet packs maybe
that's the crazy thing too like when you
talk about cell phones is that
when people tried to predict the future
you look at what what was that what was
that movie
um uh where where sylvester stallone
goes to the future and everyone's ultra
time cop i never i'm
so bad at movies it's the one where the
seashells we just talked about
no no no no no the chat's going to light
up they're like dude
how do you not remember the name
sylvester stallone in the future yeah he
gets frozen
and then uh bang that sounds like he
goes to picture wesley snipes is the bad
guy
i think i know exactly what you're
talking about i can't remember the name
of it i've never seen it but anyway like
they try to predict the future
and they couldn't fathom cell phones so
like he walks up to us demolition
demolition there we go he walks up to a
pay phone and it's a video pay phone and
that was like the thing that they
thought in the 90s in the future the pay
phones will have cameras and it's like
bro we just
technically yeah in our pockets yeah
that's so funny yeah
but people don't think like that it's
interesting i'm i'm always fascinated by
what the human
human mind is willing to comprehend like
what other technologies are we
thinking are going to be centralized
that are going to be decentralized in
the future
yeah that's a great question energy
production
maybe we have batteries but like you
can't power like uh
there's there's stuff with this for a
while now there's been research into
uh materials that when you walk they
fight it causes a vibration
electricity and it generates a current
yeah so you could literally have a phone
that just charges because you're walking
right but guess what they don't want
that either so the other way to think
about it also
is that a lot of this stuff probably
already exists right and it exists
within the military
but the governments don't want to give
you that because that doesn't that gives
you too much power right within your own
home like i think about the concept of
being able to do
to charge your own phone i mean that's
literally apple right now has become
so non-innovative since steve jobs died
it's actually like the worst company
that still exists like just waiting
i i i pray that elon musk just kind of
takes them out and creates like the
e-phone and like because they're not
actually innovative anymore and he's
done a terrible job
um since steve jobs died uh tim cook has
now their whole method of selling phones
just keep changing the battery every
couple of years if you realize that so
they're actually their model of making
money now relies on now you have to buy
20 new cables and things to connect and
like
you have to constantly charge things all
the time which was the exact opposite of
what steve jobs vision was
um but apple would do everything to
suppress something that could just
charge itself because that's literally
how they're making all of their money
now right so
there's al also once you're in that sort
of big
tech bubble you know silicon bubble and
and they work so closely with the
government and they're fighting for
government contracts like they don't
actually want the world to advance
to the point where they're not needed
you know what i mean so like after
discovering electricity like
of course they want to make sure they
can control it imagine if there was
something you could just generate your
own electricity in your backyard and you
wouldn't have to pay
con edison or whatever whoever it is
that you pay so the government's job is
to also make sure that we get tech
after they figured out how to profit off
of tech you know i think apple is a
really good example
of if you if you look at apple's inner
workings what you're saying i don't
innovate anymore it's kind of like our
political space right now
it's become tribalist why do you buy the
iphone well you gotta buy the iphone
what's good about it
it's iphone just works it's better and
that's where with a lot of people being
like
here's what i support and why and they
have no real good reason it's just oh
it's also suppression so they great
they build the system to suppress new
technology from coming in and i go
through this all the time
my husband is actually now making the
switch away from apple which is great
but the thing is is
when they were innovative and great and
everything spoke each other and steve
job was live it was like yes i want the
apple phone i want the apple computer
because it makes everything super
seamless but now they're not innovating
anymore so they just want to make it so
that like well do you really want to
change your computer and your laptop and
this core is not going to fit i mean
they took away the concept it was the
one thing all the countries agreed on
was like the universal
headphones yeah right and apple took it
away right so now you have to buy the
little piece to connect your thing to
and it's horrible right you can't just
buy like i bought a pair of dre beats
the other day in the airport and then
was like oh wait but now my dre beats is
not going to
go into what used to be universal and we
all agreed on because apple needs to
make money so you also have to buy a
little
it's horrible it really is but this is
where it is well now tech is actually
trying to
inconvenience you rather than to
convenient to you you know that the
i could be wrong with this i'm pretty
sure the first light bulb that was ever
like
made is still in a firehouse in new york
and it's still going after like 100
years
oh wow yeah so i guess what they try to
say is well the filament was expensive
but it lasted forever and so they needed
a filament that would
sell more yeah and that's uh that's how
they make money that's right i'm looking
up the first light bulb
i still believe i don't know if it was
so a conspiracy theory but like you
cannot tell me that back in the day
when every time iphone had a new phone
suddenly our phones would have issues
and i'm like this is 100
like don't don't think i'm an idiot you
think that i think you're so noble that
like you don't know how to
send out a little bug to the phone that
you created to make sure we have to buy
the next phone
which by the way i was cool with that
updating your phone for a couple years
the
charger thing should be a crime like
they just have like
it's not faster it's apple is actually
extremely
inconvenient now i mean just how many
chords it takes to make things speak to
each other i honestly think steve jobs
is like rolling over in his grave
this is confirmed check this out bbc
apple find for slowing down old iphones
oh it it wasn't a conspiracy conspiracy
theory proves
i knew i was like it's just impossible
like every single time like oh suddenly
i'm at the apple store saying
something's wrong i'm like well you can
just give you the new phone here we go
yeah they're just pressing a button
being like detonate old one
i guess what was happening is that you'd
get a software update and then it would
generate and that's why i never update
my phone and my husband gets so upset
with me and i'm like
honey i'm telling you every time i
update my phone it has more issues than
solves
and it's not going to hate the ios
mandatory update and it's like but it's
working when i want to update it but
it's it's not new bugs and new fixes
it's like
here's here's the out-of-context clip
already leftists are going to put up a
clip where it's like candace owens
criticizes capitalism
oh gosh yeah yeah let's go deeper yeah
because it's not it's crony capitalism
corruption the galaxy s5 because you
could take the battery out of the back
because they were like oh your phone's
always spying on you i was like okay i'm
taking my battery out worst case
scenario and after the
the s5 that all the batteries are
embedded in the machine now you can't
take it apart by the way just let me
think about that when you're talking
about your phone
spying on you like i am always amazed
also like in taking a look at
humanity like i like just like take
myself out because i can just look at
humanity and just how foolish we are
like
there are human beings that have alexa
in their home
right and they really think that one day
you have alexa here
right there oh my gosh they really think
that one day jeff bezos sat down and
said i really like to help people turn
on their lights
i just i think i need to help them it's
amazing how much privacy people will
give up
for a tiny bit of convenience like just
get up and turn your lights off right
and so when this came out
the first thing that came to my mind was
clearly
they make their money off of selling
data it's also the whole foods thing
right so like if you go to whole foods
like i do like
now that jeff bezos took over whole
foods they will literally
take like you know they'll say oh can
you put in your amazon prime thing and
put on your amazon prime
you'll spend 900 and they'll give you 10
cents off and it's like clearly that's
an
exchange happening right so they're
willing to give those 10 cents to know
everything that you bought and to create
a profile about you and what you like
and what your interests are
like he's not just giving you 10 cents
for putting in your amazon prime
and obviously alexa is spying on you
that's common sense some of these
stories start popping up and i said this
right when it came out i was like
clearly this is spying in your home
they're convincing you
just by on yourself right and then those
stories came out where like the police
showed up
after a wife and a husband got into a
fight and like it's good they shut up
they they showed up because
there was a man that was like beating
his girlfriend right my husband and wife
his boyfriend and girlfriend
and the police showed up and she didn't
say call 9-1-1 right she didn't take all
my one so like the most interesting part
of the story was that no one called
9-1-1 but alexa decided to call 901
because she lit did anybody see smart
house and disney like
come on dude smart house did you ever
watch that at the disney show i mean
maybe because i watched it and i was
like eight but it was the idea of like
your house got too smart and i'm telling
you like that is i'm like your house
you just do not turn off your own lights
i guess is what i'm saying this is a
long way to say the
new way to say hey internet turn off
your own lights yeah i've seen
stories where they like have the front
doors like can be automated by these
machines
and uh for like your delivery person but
like random people are getting access to
the house
they have deadbolts that are wireless
that connect to apps and you can
you can say to your computer like open
the door as you're pulling up and it'll
open it for you
nothing if it there's now to turn on
your oven your car all of that stuff
because nobody actually reads the
privacy agreement it's like they can at
any time
just zap into wherever they want to be
which is why and by the way that's a
great thing when like a criminal's on
the loose
and trying to find them and then they
can just zap in and find someone like
there's
there's no such thing now of like the
nine-day chase right they find those
guys in like hours right
because the the world is so
technologically advanced the downside of
that is that
um i don't know people that think that
jeff bezos and bill gates are
philanthropists it's like guys they
didn't become the richest man in the
world
the richest man in the world is not a
philanthropist you know what i mean
well he's selling something the
dangerous thing about surveillance is
that
sometimes we do things that are illegal
but we ultimately decide shouldn't be
and if people aren't allowed to ever
engage in any kind of
rule bending then you just you collapse
under authoritarianism
right people eventually become super
rigid it was i was talking with this
hacker moxie marlon spike
and he said it's the easiest way to
understand look at all the states that
are legalizing marijuana
how would people know they wanted to
legalize it unless they were breaking
the law
now imagine that concept cameras in
every room everyone being spied on
you would never explore that and then
you get crazy people like hitler who are
you know trying to bring up as little as
possible he would make stuff
legal that was horrible like you can't
just because something's legal doesn't
mean it's right or even good it can be
horribly
disastrously evil so you know if these
things are listening to every word and
then they make something illegal like
talking about like
us having this conversation right they
they do listen how do you think it knows
when you call its name
it's all listening it's always listening
and people just don't think like that
and i remember
talking to my and she's like well it's
just nice she's like you know siri or
alexa whoever it is there's all these
people are in your lives now and they
she turns on the lights and i'm like was
it that much of an inconvenience when
turning off your own lights like was it
that really the thing that got you to
give up all your data and your private
conversations with your husband like
come on you're late you're laying in bed
and you're like your eyes are half
closed and you're like reaching
you can't do it you just want to be like
yo dude i'm like what time is it
because i just don't want to look at a
clock i just want to listen i asked that
machine
like five times today what time it is i
just didn't want
i don't have a clock i don't want my
phone in your pocket i don't want to
look at it it hurts my
my eyes when i'm waking up i love this
idea for the uh
the zoo hypothesis about like maybe
where like the earth is a big zoo
reality show or whatever
because now they're tracking everything
we're doing they're listening to
everything and if we really were living
in like the truman show
well people got cameras on their phones
you're like you're in the bathroom
and you're on your phone as a camera
pointing at your face yeah american dad
made a joke about that they were like
all the cia does is watch people take
dumps from the from their front-facing
cameras
i mean i i on my computer my apple
computer i do put like
a little piece of tape on it zuckerberg
yeah yeah i don't know that's another
thing it's like look
always look what the tech people are
doing like what's like really
interesting to consider is none of them
allow their kids to have smartphones
they don't want them to have facebook
and a lot of them why why would somebody
create something that they don't want
their child to use dude when we were
building minds i co-founded mines um we
um
we were like how addictive do we want to
make this we were designing like the
game of some gamification stuff and
we kind of agreed like 80 82 because if
you go but you can go
all the way if you want to make it so
it's like heroin digital heroin i mean
you can do that to people
and they do that that's their jobs come
and make it as addictive as possible
we want as much you know traction on the
site repetitive traction
yeah well even the scroll mechanism like
the refresh thing was designed after
casinos because it's addicting
like you know to refresh refresh refresh
that was discovered
yeah it was designed after casinos to
make it more addicting and it's just
people just don't think about it like
they just don't know and i'm just
i'm just constantly conscious
of technology constantly conscious of
the technocrats i consider everything
in terms of how they probably think and
it's just amazing every time
people for a little bit of convenience
will give up all their privacy time and
time again
convenience yeah giving up your security
uh
giving up your freedom in exchange for
security and that's really the theme of
kobit 19. right
[Laughter]
that really is i guess you know to
extend it into what's going on today
it's it's amazing like
to what people are celebrating as wins
and just
it's it's almost it makes you question
whether or not the master and slave
relationship is almost normal
you get and when i say that i'm not
saying it's good i'm saying is it normal
because when i see these people that
seek to enslave themselves
despite being told the truth despite
being told like you know like people
don't not all people want freedom is i
guess what i'm learning now like
my people find it easier to be enslaved
we had uh we had janmi park on she's a
north korean defector this was last week
and she
she explained to us that when she
finally made it out of north korea
through years of slavery in china
traveling through the which is a gobi
desert
yeah based in south korea she said it
was painful to experience freedom
and that if north korea offered her food
she would have gone back wow
yeah she the reason she said she left
was that she was starving
and so she she looks across the bay and
she sees china and she's like
maybe if i go there there's food that
was the sole motivating factor
freedom was painful to you know you got
to be responsible for yourself
right i wrote about that in my book like
you know freedom is actually something
that's very difficult and just because
you're given freedom doesn't really mean
much if you're not willing to be
responsible for your freedom and most
people don't want to be responsible for
their freedom so just listening to
governor
to government orders it's easy it's a
system that they can plug themselves
into
the mentality of a slave i can i can
plug myself into this they can tell me
exactly what to do
and i'm comfortable with that and the
idea of removing
government and having to think for
yourself like that's scary to a lot of
people
and and justifiably because if someone
makes the wrong decision and they have
all the power they could end up hurting
a lot of people
even suffering consequences we got this
big story that that's been trending
today i think it's like hundreds of
thousands of tweets about tucker carlson
saying this is being spotted by the
bottom administration
there's there's reports coming out there
like not even fox news believes it
but i i first of all this is a huge
story but when
you were talking you're just talking
about technology and giving up all of
our security and everything tucker
mentioned that
a whistleblower contacted him and
explain and told them information about
a story that could have only come from
his texts or his emails
but think about that right we we we view
using our cell phones as a convenience
we use we see our emails as a
convenience
but it's also normal and now we don't
realize that we've given up some of our
security in exchange for using text and
email like we didn't realize that was
that was an exploit that the nsa or
your political rivals could use against
us yeah i mean i was on a show last
night when he
said this and i mean just knowing tucker
was obviously telling the truth
tucker's not a person he would never
introduce anything on a show that
it wasn't real research and he wasn't
100 confident what he was saying he's
not just lingering something in front of
someone's face
there's no effort to tantalize the
public with what he's saying and you
know it's a big story but it's also
common sense
you know especially with this government
right this totalitarian regime of biden
where we can't even say things that are
true you can't even tell the truth when
you're censoring a lot of people for
literally
telling the truth of what happened to
them right i i do
kind of like something feels off about
saying the totalitarian regime of biden
because while i do recognize there's
certainly a lot of authoritarianism
they're going after the grannies from
january 6. giving credit for that to
biden
well it's not well so when you say
solitary regimen biden like you know
he's the puppet
to the puppet he just put there right he
doesn't know what he's doing like
obviously he's not the mastermind of the
biden regime the binding regime is just
like it's jill
yeah it's it's not even jill i mean
these people need to realize these
people
for years the people that became
president are
selected by oligarchs you know they
decide who they want to be president
obama was picked you know they had them
run they're in with the media the media
is
is just you study propaganda you don't
recognize it when it's right in your
face right
mainstream media is literally meant to
control the way you think i mean it's
called tv
programming for a reason it is
programming your mind uh you know you
know you can take a
num that's on a conspiracy there you can
take a basic marketing class and learn
that you know like
certain colors make you react a certain
way music you know supplemental
messaging in stores buy it buy it buy it
you know
we had uh bannon on the show and a lot
of people in our audience were surprised
at what bannon was saying like he said
tax the rich he's like these people are
ripping you off we got to tax the rich
and people who watch this are like whoa
the media said he was like far right he
was a fascist he was a white supremacist
sounds like an occupy wall street guy
right right that's the rich yeah they
i mean they believe everything i mean
there are people that are so invested
and and they
the funny part is they are the ones that
call everybody nazis and they know so
little
about nazis they know so little about
germany they don't even know what
fascism is they don't even know they are
the fascists when they say censor at
censor they don't understand it because
they're not meant to understand it
because there's been this sort of
rinsing of history
and they just think everything they
don't like is a nazi and they don't know
actually what the nazis are and it's
you know how did hitler accomplish what
he accomplished right because he
controlled the media
he controlled the media you couldn't say
anything and that's exactly what's
happening a glowing profile piece about
joe biden
jill biden and people go okay well why
was trump attacked because he wasn't in
the establishment the oligarchs didn't
pick him
right we didn't get into a meeting and
say we want our guy in the office if
they had
they would have said he was the best
person like we saw about obama
you could not find bad information on
obama yeah right because that's
that's they control the media and they
control people's minds and there are
people that are walking around in
america right now and they genuinely
believe that i am a black white
supremacist like they're that far
deluded
like it's like at the dave chappelle
sketchup yeah it is and they believe it
because that's what they're told every
day by the media they watch you know
candace oh and she's just a black white
supremacist she just
woke up one day and said i want to help
create a society that i can't live in
yeah that's how can i help oppress
myself
this is it's the perfect example of
cognitive dissonance and how
how are we supposed to progress how are
we supposed to solve our problems
when you have an entire faction that
bases their world view off of paradoxes
like there are a bunch of like like you
being a black white supremacist
it's not a possible thing it's like
clayton bigsby was a joke yeah they
literally believe it
yeah they do they literally believe it
they the joke has become real life
parody has now become real life right
and you know the first thing is it's
it's
it starts i think with taking power away
from the education system i am now a
huge
believer in homeschool homeschooling and
like i know you were just showing me
your mom does math videos i'm a huge
believer now you know there
there there's a constant effort to dumb
children down in school and i'm not
talking about a little bit i'm talking
about kids cannot do basic
math equations um and yet they're
learning critical
race theory they're learning about
emotions and how to just react without
actually knowing why you're reacting
they know nothing about history but love
to throw out terms like nazi
and fascist and um they're just
emotional babies
and so this sort of blubbering of the
american mind
can only be reversed if you take
take your children on the education
system and go back to where this country
began plymouth
you know when they when they landed in
plymouth rock it was a bunch of moms
being like i'll take monday you take
tuesday it was homeschooling and it was
about community outreach organization
um i definitely will not put my child
through the public school system
in america and the private school system
is questionable now too because
the government the federal government is
overreaching there's all these different
requirements now
even if you want to homeschool because
kanye you know i was with him at the end
of last year and he wanted to start a
homeschool thing and he was talking to
me about all of the roadblocks
in california to prevent that from
happening because the government wants
your children they want to make sure
your children are dumb
think about what's going on with all the
critical race theory stuff these these
school board battles
then you have at the same time one of
one of trump's campaign uh promises for
in 2020 was school choice we see a big
push from conservatives about
parents having the right to choose where
their kids will go to school maybe a
voucher program
and the democrats say it's racist to do
that no you can't allow that because
then the rich people are gonna do this
that or otherwise
then we see what they're doing they're
it's not this is this is the trick that
the left is doing right now with
critical race theory they're saying
no one is teaching critical race theory
because no one is showing the book
white fragility which is critical white
studies nobody is reading kimberly
crenshaw you're all mistaken what
they're doing is
they're applying critical race theory
into everything else yeah
then they're indoctrinating kids with
psychotic nonsense
and then when the parents complain what
what just happened we saw this in
loudoun county they arrested one guy
because he was just standing there
saying i want to speak and they're like
the event's over you're not allowed
yeah he's like well i i was told i was
allowed to speak and then they they
arrest him no he didn't get arrested i
think he got
detained and received a summons so i
think that's technically an arrest one
guy got into a fight
but this battle is going to be big you
know yeah but it's also like what
it's i'm always amazed when i go around
and i you know get speak on stage and
then one question i get is what can we
do what can we do it's like
it's your children and they're being
preyed upon by predators it's it's like
going around and have people ask me hey
candace like i went to the playground
today and
a man showed my child pornography what
what should i do it's like
what it's literally what's happening
they're showing children pornography and
parents are like i called the
administration what do you mean you
called them and she called the cops
you know like teacher not teachers not
immune from pressing charges against
teachers for doing crazy things and
if you're telling me that you if you
took a [ __ ] to the playground a random
stranger that's what these teachers are
they're random strangers right they're
random strangers that have gone through
radical
um the radical education system they're
also the dumbest people by the way
people that get education degrees it's
fascinating thomas soul has a book
um called inside the education system
the lies the dog
the dogma and the indoctrination and he
talks about how
in terms of like their placements in
their universities
the dumbest are people that get
education degrees which is really
fascinating right
um and so you're getting these people
that are not the brightest but are
convinced of their own intelligence
because they're being handed these
degrees and acolytes and they go to
teach like
about the kids you went to school with
like people that became teachers they
were really nice like for at least high
school like they were the nice kids
but they were not the brightest in our
school like they were like the you know
c minus kids they wanna be computers and
they should like great uh we need
teachers i i support you as i love
teachers
but they are convinced of their own
education and whatever they're told to
teach they teach
right and and i i know i'm painting a
broad brush here but
so they go in they they teach your kids
all the stuff you don't know them
they're strangers and yet you're too
fearful to remove your child
from what has obviously now become a
predatorial situation
right you're preying on kids you're
teaching them race you're teaching them
how to hate one another you're
separating kids and saying you know why
are you embarrassed about your white
privilege it's actually happened in new
york school
like go around the room and talk about
why you're you should feel guilty for
being white
your children are being attacked that's
a predator remove them that's i mean
you're a parent
forget it when they're when they're
teaching a lot of the stuff which
borders on inappropriate sexual behavior
you think the police are actually gonna
do anything there's laws they have to
they have to literally if you're a child
within that teacher
or she was a workshop they do the
workshops now justine eng was her name
um i can't think of her last name but it
was justine something
and she's the one that did both of the
workshops she was one that showed the
pornography to the 16 year olds at the
dalton school in new york city
and she was the same one who showed the
cartoon to first graders about
masturbation
about how it feels to touch themselves
let my
child in the first grade have seen a
cartoon about masturbation and i'm going
to go
if you literally showed a child on a
playground a cartoon not masturbation
that's disseminating sexual
uh material to a minor yep point blank
if you go to the police and you follow
report there's no law saying to police
well
it happened in school so you can't do
anything as it was taught to them
no wow the second one parent has the
courage to do that
right and a teacher gets arrested this
crap is going to stop because teachers
are going to be like
let's go look do you know what i'm
saying i'm not getting arrested like
you're
you're a sexual offender in my opinion
justine
register as a sexual offender justine
fonte i think
renee she should be in prison this is
from a month ago columbia prep students
and parents
real after class on porn literacy i
can't say the words
i can't say the words that were being
taught it's like this was a class that
taught
if i say the words youtube will maybe
even take this video incestuous porn
like like incestuous yeah in class and
none of the parents there was no
permission slip that went out it's
disgusting first kindergarten
that was a 16 year olds but she also was
the same one who did the first graders
the thing is these people have that was
like that was a cartoon about
masturbation for the first graders
about how it feels good to touch
yourself and it was talking it was a
cartoon
they give these people tight the title
of teacher and that it's similar to
having the title of president
if you win the title because you got
picked then you get this type but the
real teachers are like
on the internet like jordan peterson he
makes videos no one has to be there
people choose to listen and learn but
these people are people are
stuffed in and forced to listen to this
person with a with a
badge that says something that's what
they've realized that these kids are a
captive
audience that and and they were do you
remember uh when the lockdown first
started
they started doing remote schools and
one of the teachers was caught someone
recorded this where they were like i'm
worried the parents are going to find
out what we're teaching their kids now
mm-hmm
yeah and that's the thing and the
government understands this and again
the irony being everyone is calling
people you're literally hitler
you're literally not well what was not
to youth okay what was not to youth
it was a way to plug them into a system
to get to get the children
on board into the system and to believe
everything that the government believes
well that's the exact same thing that's
happening right now that it didn't
change because it's happening on
american soil
they obviously understood for six hours
a day they have your children
and now they're rinsing the schools of
heart academics they don't math is
racist that's an initiative by bill
gates looking look it up bill gates
started an initiative saying that
white's
that math and encouraging children to
get the right answer is a form of white
supremacy
he's calling it equitable math and now
he is pushing for the curriculum to stop
teaching kids to get the right answer
and just allow them to tell you how they
got the wrong one and they should still
get a 100.
make your child dumb check this out
check this out we went to uh
we were talking about this yesterday i
went to a skate park over the weekend
and
skate park's notorious for kids being
punk rock fighting with security guards
vandalizing property and yet the
graffiti was at the skate park
black lives matter trans rights are
human rights that was the graffiti and i
started laughing i'm like
that's like an amazon.com like big bold
thing when you go on it's like
it's like it's like a it's a it's an
organization it is mainstream pop
culture
the embassies fly the flag and little
kids think they're being rebels
by adopting a message that is used by
u.s embassies and
that is youth indoctrination and they
don't get it because these kids they're
kids right and the problem is that
the adults are crazy right so the adult
those are totally looney tunes right so
the problem is is twofold it's
that there's some weird olympic event to
be the most woke parent like i was so
accepting and loving because my child is
a non-binary species
and it's amazing right that's like the
new thing i'm like i'm
such an amazing parent my child the
non-binary mermaid
and then you couple that with the
education and that's reinforcing that
okay so how is it possible that i went
to school this notion is non-binary
we didn't have a single child that was
non-binary yes we didn't have it right
so it's obviously not natural for all of
these kids
popping up now doing videos saying i'm
non-binary because none of us had this
issue when we were growing up and none
of the people that i went to school with
now that's even an option have opted
into this right because it just wasn't
even presented to them right it wasn't
presented so it's not like
oh they were just suppressing this and
then now that it's a thing i have all
these kids that i graduate with that are
like i'm
i was always non-binary you know it was
like tomboys like i was a tomboy when i
was in fifth grade
this is why we got we got to be careful
about saying it's just critical race
theory in schools no it's
critical theory in general it's like the
marxist oppressor versus oppressed
it is critical gender theory it is
critical race theory it is critical
white studies
it is the idea that everything is bad
you're the bad guy i'm always right no
matter what happens
you know uh you're the problem right
he's like why whirl the dice why roll
the dice people are
i would never say my child they're
getting the internet three-year-olds are
on the internet so we're talking about
these technocrats keeping their kids off
the internet
and there's a reason because when a
three-year-old goes on and looks at like
cartoons but then it turns out it's a
youtube cartoon of hitler dancing with
bugs bunny and you're like what is this
and they're learning about like why it's
okay to why gender doesn't matter and it
hey it's raising your children the
internet is raising children and a good
example of this like in the mainstream
is so dwayne wade right he has a child
who has come out as a trans
i don't know i don't even know what he
had a son
who now identifies as a daughter right
and i remember watching the story
and you know him and gabrielle union
came out and you know she's super woke
and
they were like so saying how like brave
and encouraged they were and like this
is just who this person was right
but then i remember seeing the photo and
um this is before
he had declared his gender as being a
woman
or girl um and seeing a photo of
his son in a crop top you know at a
pride parade
um and with long long like cardi b like
fingernails right
okay well that obviously wasn't who this
person was where'd you learn
the crop top and the long fingernails
right that's social social construct
that's a social construct right so you
can't tell me you know you can say
people have a natural affinity
okay wanted to hook up with the guy one
type of girl but you didn't learn long
finger nails right so where did your
child learn that with my question dwyane
wade
how do we start with the crop tops and
the long nails because that's not a
thing
and the answer of course is going to be
the internet because if you're on
instagram today that is a culture you
know
not even uh the kardashians um what's
the
uh kylie jenner you know the lips the
fingernails all the stuff it created an
entire culture of this
and you're a basketball player i know
how aggressive that schedule is i know
that it is hard to be a parent and be on
the road playing
um x amount of games all all year and
so what was happening while you were on
the road and he's you know in a split
home as well so it was with his
you know with his his mother um it's
likely that the internet helped to raise
your kid and this is how we got here but
rather than have that conversation which
is much more severe and hard to have
we're just going to go ahead and allow
your you know 12 year old at least then
12 year old to make a permanent life
decision
okay three-year-old three dwayne wade
three uh his trans daughter knew her
identity since she was three years which
is scary because i babysat
three-year-olds who literally think
they're mermaids like i've had a
three-year-old in a tub
she cried and screamed into a temper
tantrum because she told me she was a
mermaid
and i cannot imagine giving credence to
that and saying you know what
sleep in the bath tonight because i am
sorry and i
can't wait to go to tell the other
parents how amazing and woke i am
because i'm accepting you as a mermaid
i'm pretty sure when i was three and my
mom asked me what i wanted to be this is
a true story i said a pumpkin
i like that yeah it was like i was just
like a little kid and that was like a
story my mom would say
people would be like what does he want
to be and she's like well he said
pumpkins yeah i really wanted to be a
power ranger
yes yeah i still kind of do but you know
you always join the marines
nobody recognized my power ranger skills
which power ranger
um that's a very good question that's a
very good question by the way
in the retrospect how racist yeah the
yellow ones asian the black ones black
the white one's white the pink one's a
girl oh so funny
i love the pirates amazing probably the
robot or would you build your own thing
for all them right
yeah like i love i like like mighty
morphin power rangers was it
it was it's so weird though like wait
how did the original power rangers
happen where they're like sitting there
like let's make the yellow ranger asian
yeah
i know it's so great it's so great i
know
i'm sure they're already canceled we
just have to look google it i'm sure
someone realized that 20 years later
it goes back to like the 70s there was a
show that was like the first one where
there was like five people in different
colored outfits that would come together
to form like a big creature and then it
became voltron that it became the power
rangers yeah i was power rangers i don't
know that original show i don't watch i
don't know what it's called i have no
idea okay yeah
voltron yeah voltron was the 80s version
they were all these cat machines they
would ride around and they'd form this
giant guy who had a big sword
big robot 42. okay it was hot 86.
i like the green power dinosaur remember
when um
mario lopez was he was on someone's show
yeah
and he said i don't think
three-year-olds know that they're trans
you know what show that was
what was it the canis owen show that was
your show
he got in trouble he did he came on my
show and it was
what was so bizarre and mario's a friend
of mine and like we're so bizarre like
we just didn't go there
like it was like sort of just it was
such a non-question it wasn't like
i was pushing him it was just sort of
like what's it like in hollywood now
because
it's the woke olympics and he was very
nice and he just said like
you know for me personally like you know
i understand when you're adult do what
you want but
just let kids be kids yeah you know and
they
and it was funny because it was like two
months later after the interview and
then suddenly like mario lopez is
trending and there
and everyone listened to it was like he
literally said as nice as possible like
hey let kids grow up
and um they were in to cancel him and
yeah
he did apologize but i will say it was a
very like
it's always the same apologies like copy
and pasted where like you have to say it
and you know i was bummed that he
apologized but also
not bummed because he's a great he's a
fantastic person really a fantastic
human being i think him and his wife
are such an example of what it means to
just be a very present family i'm very
impressed by them
and just imagine everything you have
being gone in a moment
unless you do this and so yes i i would
i would stand by my guns but when you
have three small kids
it gets harder and it gets harder and it
gets harder right here but think about
the future for those kids
100 true but he's probably he's on the
other side thinking of the future for
those kids right so it's like whatever
schools they go out or maybe they go to
private school they have a house he's
got a mortgage to pay so i've tried to
be
more understanding um i think when you
have the
autonomy to do it it's a lot easier
there's no excuse when there's like a
person who's like no family
and just takes it i'm like come on man
but i get it because
he ju and by the way i'm on your side i
think he would have done that and he
would have been a hero
and other doors would have been open but
it's a very big risk to ask somebody to
take
who's that established it's true and
i've said this like i understand people
who have kids who are scared to speak
out
but it really sounds like you're betting
the future will be communist wokeness
and so you want to keep your family safe
but if everyone
said no then the future wouldn't be let
me tell you if i
could just maybe one day i might i won't
but
like the a-list celebrities that are in
my inbox that i speak to
you would be shocked at how many of them
hate it i mean
it's all they are definitely i think the
majority of them hate it
right actually the majority of them hate
it and i have contributions to them on
the phone
and i'm just like man you're like top
player in the nba it'd be amazing if you
spoke out like hey you're the number one
i get this one two
r b singer you know and it's like and
they can't do it and so they just talk
to us
almost like we're like on their
therapist you know or they can just let
it go
i've had people rock stars skateboarders
call me some nearly crying
like i'm scared man you know i could i
could live i lose everything at a moment
i don't know what to do
and i'm like you're gonna call me and
talk to me for two hours it's like
therapy it really is it is
they can't they're up to anybody they're
scared they're terrified they know they
can talk to me because they watch my
show and they trust it and i'm like
you have how many millions of followers
you could come out right now and just
say guys
i do not think this is okay i think you
need to chill and they're like yeah but
i'll lose everything and i'm like you're
a millionaire
dude okay i mean that's why kudos to
that guy actually uh the mumford and
sons guy i read his piece today actually
was first when i read it i think he
released it five days ago and just
saying like i couldn't
you know i knew that i could lose
everything but the same at the end of
the day like my soul wouldn't sit right
if i
allowed this radicalism to be the reason
and he just stepped down from the band
because there's things that are more
important in life and
i think people like him are heroic and
to platform that
i think the more and more people that
kind of inch forward and do it
eventually it'll just be an avalanche
you look at what happens with veritas
you know when someone blows the whistle
and goes to veritas what happened that
facebook guy raised half a million bucks
because there are there are people who
will support you
when you come out and you be brave you
will not be left
holding the bag and i think what james
is doing is incredible because he's
proving it
yeah he's he's saying be brave and then
he's like and this guy got half a
million dollars
that's true i was just thinking is it
going to take like another jesus or
socrates that speaks the truth speaks
the truth society revolts
executes the person and then 50 or 100
years later we realized what have we
done
why what if we this person was saying
the right thing
but no it's not going to take that
because we have people like james people
it's happening this upsurgence is
happening all at once and people are
making
half a million bucks after the fact so
we've gotten we've evolved
are you are you comparing james o'keefe
to jesus or soccer all of us baby
we all have that in us to speak up
against the empire and that's
if we do it together true it's funny
because i just recently reread plato's
apology
and it's just incredible history repeats
itself and you know calling out the
corruption of senators and
and the courage that took you know that
there was no upside other than you know
death
and and to and to have it be noble and
you know i hear that same message that
was kind of my mentality when i sort of
jumped out of the window and
you know i know that was kanye's
mentality if you listen to his music i
mean a lot of
the courage that i have is because i
listen to so much kanye west and
to me i i don't have the slave mentality
right so
i'd rather be executed running away
right
towards freedom like i'm definitely the
slave that would have run away from the
plantation i'm the harriet tubman i'm
like you know i'm the kanye west i'm the
you know pick a point in time i'm the
socrates asking people
walking down the street asking them
questions about what they think but
because freedom is natural to me
but i don't know as i was saying earlier
if it's natural for everybody i i wonder
now as i look at this society and look
at copenhagen people that were like
please lock us down please put us in our
homes please tell me when to see my mom
and dad i'm like maybe people just
want to be enslaved and this model of
you know slave and master meaning
government and people that it controls
will never be broken freedom is scary
yeah freedom is dangerous
for those of us that are adults we're
okay with that yeah
you know what i did today i went and i
picked a bunch of wild berries and then
i cooked them and ate them wow i see
that's i got to get on that like one
thing that i
am definitely lacking in is i think it
is so important for us to know how to
farm
yeah it's like so important i mean the
amount of control you give up when you
can't
feed yourself yeah is that's like the
next unlock the next layer of the
candace owens game well i i want
to tone spawn when you pull the weed out
super smooth it's so rewarding and my
last name is farmer
legally oh nice i just got married so
now it's even weirder to be like candace
farmer and literally farms
i want to talk about you mentioned the
lockdown stuff because uh we got a story
it's a bit personal i'm talking about a
friend of mine who said he was cool with
me sharing his posts he did make them
publicly
either way and right now we have the
delta variant
now i think new york i'm not sure if
it's new york they're saying they're not
going to do another lockdown
but la is saying we're bringing back the
mask guidelines because the delta
variant is scary
the first thing i'm going to say is a
disclaimer to this i am i look
i'm going to be telling a story about
one person i don't want this to be a
shocking story
like i don't want to be shock value or
fear fear-mongering on the vaccine or
anything like that
i just think these are things we need to
talk about brett weinstein talks a bit
about this on his show he's been
demonetized he's been
given a strike over this so i'm going to
say this talk to your doctor
raise your concerns with your doctor if
you're unsatisfied you get a second
opinion these are normal things
that people do no one's forcing you to
like listen to only one person you can
talk to as many doctors as you want just
make sure you're talking to your
facebook who's forcing you to listen to
one person and that's dr fauci but go
ahead
yes fair point fair point youtube too
but what i mean is like in your daily
life you go to your doctor and if you
don't like what they're saying you call
another doctor
and you keep in these conversations and
i've talked to people who've had people
on the show said they've had good
doctors who have given them sound advice
but i want to show you this because this
is uh uh this
pertains a lot to people i'm not trying
to be mean to my friend he's a good
friend of mine i've known since as a kid
but a lot of people just go along with
whatever's being said so i'll give you
the gist of it
my friend uh got the vaccine
and he got nerve damage and now his legs
and he has he has problems in his legs
and arms he was in the hospital for this
and he said that after a second second
dose this was over a month ago
he started feeling pins and needles in
his arms and legs happened to my
girlfriend pins and needles but she had
it instantly
he said it was a couple days later and
then eventually he was struggling to
walk he was having tremors
and his arms and legs felt like they
weighed 120 pounds he ends up in the
hospital
he just posted a message i tweeted it
out he said i made a hard decision today
i am officially stepping away from music
for the foreseeable future
it breaks my heart that my injury has
led to this but with complications to my
living situation as well as constant
fatigue and pain
i can no longer effectively serve my
musical projects to the best of my
abilities
i love my bandmates and our fans and
friends it's been a wonderful 20 years
of shows and great times i hope i can
return to the stage one day soon until
then
peace and love again i'm not trying to
say this is indicative of every single
person this has happened to
i just think it's important that we have
these honest conversations because if
you suppress them
what happens people freak out they get
scared they get paranoid okay
it's simple something bad happened to my
friend
what i'm trying to point out is that he
had already had he had already had the
the coven
so he had he was immune he wanted to
play shows
the stores these these venues they don't
know anything about your medical history
so they just say i don't care if you got
the vaccine you can play
so he goes to get it and then he ends up
getting it and what they think now is
there have been doctors recommending
that if you've had the covet
editor within a certain time you can't
get vaccinated until a certain time
after something like that yeah
well none of this is none of this is no
it's no longer conspiracy that we're
talking about because
now the cdc had to look into myocarditis
the kids that were having the heart
inflammation now it's a warning
as of yesterday they said there's now
officially a warning and you can look up
which
on the pfizer and the madonna vaccine
regarding potential heart inflammation
side effects which is incredible
um because it took this long for them to
admit it and we've all known this
because we're talking to our friends and
we've been censored so there's so much
i mean there's so many people that
should be sued for censoring this
information
because people that if we had just known
and had an honest conversation i
actually think more people would be
inclined to get the vaccine
if there was an honest conversation as
opposed to the mass and ships that we've
the fact that you even have to start
with
i'm just saying you know is the reason
people don't trust big farmer trust
youtube or
trust facebook because they're not
allowed to talk about what's happening
and you know i'm uh
obviously a woman in her childbearing
years i had a girlfriend and i've talked
about this on my show
she's a doctor she had to get the
vaccine um got it and
you know bled for an extraordinary a
long amount of time and hasn't had a
normal
menstruation cycle since right and so
that another story that kept popping up
and now
they're looking into it you know looking
into it finally which means that enough
has happened to enough people where they
have to look into it maybe two months
from now they'll admit that
you know it's causing some effects with
menstruation who knows um
but who knows right but here is what i
will just say so we can keep this
conversation universal which will keep
us
off the ice with the youtube censorship
lords
common sense it's just not that common
anymore right
if we put a peanut in the middle of this
table peanuts are good i like peanuts i
like peanuts if every single person had
a peanut in the world
would all of us feel the same way about
peanuts some people would be dead right
peanuts yeah people have allergies right
like there are
uh me i i have a very severe allergy to
mold
like so severe shut down my life like if
there is
mold growing in a home it is it is that
bad right
and everybody has that some people can
be around both they'll be totally fine
right
so if you talk about any product
styrofoam it doesn't matter what it is
people have the strangest
allergies ever right weird allergies
some people allergic to dog hair cat
hair human hair
right um and we we watch these episodes
of all these strange things and it's
obviously because what
we're all the same that's common sense
we're not all the same we have different
backgrounds right
suddenly you apply this to medicine
and people go that's impossible that's a
conspiracy theory
that should just indicate to you the
power that big
pharma a trillion dollar industry has
where it is forcing people
right to to or or it's causing people to
not think with common sense which is
that one size does not fit all
this this is this is my main issue with
all of this
people are going to mcdonald's and
there's like a vaccine station outside
they're going to bars and they're drunk
now i want to make sure i show that
you mentioned the myocardia myocarditis
it is a fact cdc
does now issue a warning myocarditis
and pericarditis following mrna
vaccination
they do mention first thing more than
177 million people have received at
least one dose of the covet-19 vaccine
in the u.s
the cdc continues to monitor the safety
of the coveted vaccines for any health
problems that happen after vaccination
since april 201 they have been 2021
there have been more than a thousand
reports
to the vaccine adverse event reporting
system of cases of
inflammation of the heart called
myocarditis and pericarditis
happening after mrna covet 19
vaccination
these reports are rare given given the
hundreds of millions of vaccine doses
administered
and have been reported after mrna
covered vaccination particularly in
adolescents and young adults
cdc and its partners are actively
monitoring these reports by reviewing
data and medical records to learn more
about what happened
and to understand any relationship to
covet 19 vaccination
you know what else is rare death from
cobit 19.
very rare extreme exceedingly rare but
that didn't that didn't stop them from
shutting down all of society but now all
of a sudden
this myocarditis and this symptom is
rare and it's not stopping it's not
stopping them from doing the vaccines
they're not locking down the vaccine so
it's just it's an interesting thing
well when rare matters to big farmer and
when it doesn't matter big pharma and
it's interesting that
when they can make money you know
exceedingly rare is fine keep doing the
thing but if they can't make money
right exceedingly rare that it doesn't
mean anything to them it's like
covet is more dangerous than the vaccine
if you just look at like
i think it's like what point two point
three i i don't wanna get the numbers
wrong on the mortality rate from coven
it is mostly older people it is mostly
comorbidities
but of the people yeah to young people
which one's more dangerous
to the teenagers that are getting
myocardialis which one's more dangerous
yeah
so question mark well let's put question
mark let's just put a question mark
which one is more dangerous for the
teenagers
and the children crazy because they
didn't do studies for years on the
vaccines before they released
and every time people said that you know
it's still not fda
approved it's still it's um you know
it's got e-ua
emergency use authorization yeah exactly
it's got emergency use authorization
but i do think um one of them and i'm
not i don't know which ones i'm not
gonna say
is is approved for youth or something
like that like 12 to 17 they got to
prove that's true
they might just be eu eua approval yeah
when they start they're doing it younger
and younger than the eu
approval but i want to read this they
mentioned confirmed cases occurred
mostly in male adolescence
and young adults aged 16 years or older
more often after getting the second dose
than the first dose
and typically within several days of
cova-19 vaccination so i will stress
177 million doses okay you need to
decide what's right for your family
you need to ask your doctor for sound
medical advice
don't get pulled don't get medical
advice from people like me on the
internet
or from comedians or from tv doctors i
i'm trying to we
we're probably in trouble for even
talking about it right that's that's
that's the name of the game
that's how much power big farm has and
that's because bigfarmer gives billions
billions of dollars to youtube and
facebook and twitter right so right now
the youtube lords are going
oh my gosh we're getting this huge check
from big pharma and we need to make sure
that we protect that money that we get
and so
us having a conversation that should be
had which is an important conversation
about health
and how we're all different and and
people they should allow this if they
cared about the well-being of people
gets censored
because they care about their paychecks
and that's the society that we live in
right and i'll stress we're not
recommending anyone do anything
do what's good for you no for me i had a
vaccine reaction
years ago i'm not playing with it you
know i have no interest in getting the
vaccine that doesn't mean that i'm
telling you to do it or not do it i have
friends have gone in friends have not
gotten it
um and and that autonomy used to be okay
um this is
this is the line i'm trying to dance
right if you do not have conversations
about the negative then what happens to
someone who experiences the negative
they're confused and they get angry well
they go deep down into conspiracy
theories right and that's what's wrong
and that's what i've been saying
actually i think more people are less
inclined to get it now because there's
so obviously not an honest conversation
being had
so so this is what happens i tweeted the
story and i get a bunch of lefties being
like
oh you had one friend so you're saying
the millions and i'm like no
i'm not saying any of that i'm just
saying like here's a story from my
friend it's a tragic story we need to
have a conversation about what this
means and what the results will be
because it is affecting people this way
and i think people should talk to their
doctors to make sure they're getting
sound medical advice because i'm not
giving it
and just because i post one story does
it most the people i know
the overall majority no problems
whatsoever well let me we had we had a
people
we had i don't i don't want to name the
people who've come on the show talked
about this privately
because they're private informed medical
information we've had a ton of guests
who are like i have no side effects
whatsoever
but can we talk about it without getting
banned we'll see right well i mean eric
clapton had a similar response
he thought he would never play guitar
again um and yeah so i mean i think one
of the things i think is the sad like
that is most sad about it
is that what they're doing now and this
is why i did a whole episode talking
about my friend who
um you know has not had a regular
menstruation cycle since getting the
vaccine and she's like we're actually
people that did everything they told us
to do and they're being gasoline right
so
they did what they're supposed to do
they stayed locked down they didn't go
to work they lost money and then when
things opened up and the vaccine became
available they got the vaccine
so they followed all government orders
and now that same government is
gaslighting them when they say oh i had
a weird reaction they go that's not
possible
so for right now the menstruation thing
hasn't been looked into enough there's
tons of articles on it but they're like
a tear saying that's what they do
um and she's like now i'm being gaslit
from the same people that i listen to
that's a horrible feeling right and
that's why i talk about because i'm like
they're not being listened to and they
did
all of the listening and um i'll leave
it with this joke
uh what what's the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth
eight months yes but
i want to mention something too there's
two big things that i talk about with
this
i really do think there's a lot of
people online who will see a handful of
these stories and hyper focus on them
and then think like it's the apocalypse
and
i've heard some really crazy
conspiracies about the vaccine i'm like
dude there's not a zombie apocalypse
there's not like people are saying in
two years everyone's going to die and
i'm like that's insane dude that's not
going to how crazy though imagine if
that did happen
like it's not going to happen i know but
like just let's create a movie let's
create a movie right now obviously it's
not going to happen but what if it did
imagine if every person you knew
who got the vaccine died it falls over
that's crazy that's a crazy
funny movie to consider not funny i mean
terribly like horrible funny strange
funny strange yeah like whoa people want
to believe the world is this
like movie and and i tell people this
like silencers aren't real
guns oh someone just messaged me like
can you tell tim that some silencers
do sound like the movies you can you can
like treat them and make it so it's like
you can't hear it
okay okay sure but the idea that i heard
you dude thanks for messaging a spy
walks into a room and screws on the side
and goes
it's like okay okay anyway that's what
james bond did
right movies not real life okay sure
there are certainly some they're very
very quiet supporters look into it
probably subsonic rounds i don't know
enough about it but sure we're fine
apocalyptic film though right here's i'm
worried about two things
one how many uh for sure like i can talk
about my friends i think we need to have
these conversations
but how many of these news stories over
exaggerate
there was one story from the new york
post where they were like two days after
getting a vaccine a college student died
and at the bottom it's like the vaccine
had nothing to do with his death it was
like alcohol related or something like
that with kobe 19. i remember like there
was a five-year-old died of cope at 19
and then like
a little thing at the bottom said like
she also had meningitis like
oh oh my gosh okay so she probably died
from the meningitis not the
kovid 19 but she they were doing the
post-mortem testing and i notoriously
blew up the story of the governor of
connecticut who should be imprisoned for
a lie but he told saying an infant died
of covet 19.
and through my back channel because it
was a connecticut story and i'm from
connecticut and my sisters were both
pregnant at the time and this story
traumatized them
i decided to get to bible because i knew
he was lying it was why he phrased it
19 complications and then i find out
that actually the baby was suffocated by
its drug addict mother and then
post-mortem testing they tested for
covenant 19.
and that was enough to be on the list
didn't george floyd have coveted he did
yeah yeah so i mean and so it's like
it's just one of those things that's so
frustrating because like
again when the media wants to be evasive
they're evasive and then like
all of this data i know talk across from
tourists get in trouble by literally
reading the vera's data and saying
you know this is not good what we're
seeing and they're like there's no way
to confirm that data i'm like okay well
it was enough when
when people were getting coveted 19 for
you to add to the death ticker but i
guess it's not enough when people are
talking about vaccines and again only
one of those
one of those things makes you know a big
farm of money that's the double standard
that during kovid there was one viral
video apparently like someone had a
motorcycle accident and then had kovid
and i think it was a health official
from illinois who mentioned like that
will be listed yeah as a person died
with coverage
i remember watching the video we kept
hearing i mean it's really really
extreme if it saves one life
right they're like we're gonna lock
everything down and it saves one life
it's like that's
double standard right when it comes to
big pharma
when it comes to just
going 100 in one direction when it's
when it's the establishment to the left
you're allowed to we can barely even
have conversations about
adverse reactions without getting banned
on youtube well i do and i talked about
on instagram because like i said i had
i had a bad reaction to the guard of
cell vaccine and from then i just said i
will never say silent about it and
it's incredible how many women have
written me and just said thank you for
talking about this because so many women
were injured by that vaccine
you know you know what their mentality
is it was so bad
you know but you know what their
mentality is though the the officials
say
look we know that vaccine injuries are
real we know that there's a certain
percentage that's why the cdc mentions
look we had 177 million
over a thousand myocardia reports
because
they will publicly say this and i think
fauci even did
it is worth it because you save more
lives with the vaccine
than the people who get hurt by it and
the people who get hurt by it are
not likely to die and that's literally
been
their their their line of thinking it's
really fascinating because it's this
very
utilitarian versus deontological
argument the needs of the money outweigh
the needs of the few okay
we vaccinate everybody there will be
some injuries to people but that's okay
it's the trolley problem right you've
got a person on
you know you've got the five people on
one side one person on the other the
train's gonna hit the five people you
can pull the lever it'll hit the one
person but you chose to hit that one
person
right how many people probably would
just be fine
if they went to their doctors ask for
medical advice the doctor said here's
what i recommend for you and it wasn't
the vaccine and they went home and they
never got cold but nothing happened
yeah but how disgusting that people that
get covered are still being too bad to
get the vaccine that's literally science
saying to you
we are smarter than the human body and
like so those natural antibodies know
you need to get these fake ones
you know and it's so that's even more
bizarre is that like they haven't even
isolated the virus they've created a
vaccine they say
if you get the virus you know is this
will you'll have less of a chance of
dying even though as i said if you're
young you have a remarkably like
virtually non-existent chance of dying
anyways forcing you to get it to be able
to go back to school and to resume your
normal life and you know just because
i don't know they decided that's totally
necessary and again they
just they just seem so hypocritical
because it's like they either care about
the few
or they all or they don't it's the exact
opposite they're sending mixed signals
right now
they're telling us vaccines work but
then saying that if you if you don't
have the vaccine
you you should be masked and it's like
well vaccines work no no no no the delta
variant
the world health organization says now
even with the vaccine you should be
wearing a mask and socially that's new
but even before when they were saying
vaccines work right if vaccines work why
do you care
i am not vaccinated why do you care if i
am next to someone who is vex is
vaccinated because they should be
protected and we know that they're not
protected because bill maher
all of suits are coming out they got the
vaccine and they're still getting copin
19. so now what was the exercise about
if they can still catch it and his
wasn't the delta variant right
if people are still getting covet 19
after getting the vaccine
now explain to us what the song and
dance is about well this is interesting
because the youtube rules
actually say you can't state the vaccine
is a guarantee and you can't state the
vaccine
doesn't work you have to actually say it
mostly works like it's it's it's bizarre
there's a huge list of youtube's rules
and i i got an official statement from
them me too from facebook
anything that creates vaccine hesitancy
will be banned
on youtube this was interesting because
reuters came out with a story oxford did
a study on ivermecton
and they said it may be effective but
they're still doing trials i want to
make sure that's very clear because
youtube asked me to
and they said uh all that matters when
you're talking about hydroxychloroquine
and ivormectin as you mentioned
the fda says it's not approved it's not
effective
and tell people to talk to their doctor
and you should be fine
so okay we'll see if if that's enough
for them but i kind of feel like it
won't be because we've certainly been
flying close to the sun in this one
yeah common sense nine new billionaires
have been minted the governments have
extreme
extraordinary powers since this cobit 19
thing
but okay i get passionate about physical
health i'm
the the the medical industry as it i
don't know what you call it the
what do they call it where they cut
stuff out if it's if it's infected
rather than try and treat it
uh but basically it's been around since
the rockefeller built this industry uh
uh
osteopathic medicine where you'll cut
out a problem instead of trying to treat
it from the inside by treating the
lymphatic system
so this whole system is built on like
treating the blood after the fact let's
let's try and pump some
where you can fix your lymphatic
system's acidity by like eating the
right foods
hold on bro like i i genuinely
when i see these like youtube videos and
they get into it and they start talking
about what you should be doing what you
can do
i'm not a fan of that steve jobs thought
he was going to drink fruit and cure his
cancer
so like i don't i don't i don't like
there's no
cure no no i don't i don't like the idea
that's always like
i'm just stopping eating healthy i mean
i mean we gotta start at the bottom
like preventative from getting sick not
like after you get sort of
like he's correct yeah of course it's
not representative they're never trying
to like there's so many steps that can
happen before you get to like a person
that
and by the way this is kind of making me
think of when you said that like the
britney spears thing i've been kind of
talking about a lot because she kind of
just
obviously this has been a big story she
came out and says that she's been in
prison and she definitely has been and
people
i believe people should go to prison for
what they did to her because it's just
it's incomprehensible she had this very
obvious out in the front mental
breakdown but like the reason for that
mental breakdown was very clear she was
begging the paparazzi level alone they
didn't it was insane
um and it reminded me of uh when i was
in college this was actually a moment in
my life that changed my life and i will
never forget the name of the girl who
did this her name was zoe esposito
all teenage girls are like on the brink
of suicide like
we're just highly emotional i'm being
hyperbolic obviously but like
you know it's just being a teenager in
general right it's just a lot more angst
like that's one time i don't want to go
back to being a teenager
and um my boyfriend and i were in high
school we broke up and i was in
he was my high school boyfriend i was in
my freshman year of college we broke up
on the phone and i was like
devastated but i tell you like dev say
like like screaming crying like the ra
came to check on me like i was like
i couldn't stop crying wouldn't get out
of bed my dad was so scared cause he
never heard me sound like that
but he got in his car and he drove up
the two and a half hours from to
university and picked me up from my dorm
and took me home
you know like what is wrong with mike i
couldn't do i wouldn't eat nothing
and um took me to the doctor because
that's what you do i guess your child's
sad to take him to the doctor and the
doctor wrote me a full prescription for
xanax
because he's like you know you're crying
a lot xanax will help you do it the
anxiety of his breakup
and whatever so i go back to university
that night and i've got this
um xanax prescription and this girl zoe
thank god um met me in the dorm because
she's waiting for me to get back and she
talks to me i'm like well the doctor
gave me xanax
and she's like i'm just going to ask you
a question she was like why are you
going to take that pill
and i was like because i'm really sad
and she was like why are you sad like
why are you so sad and i said you know
because me and so-and-so broke up and
she said
i have this thing that if you can answer
the question why right
you don't need a pill like that's a
human emotion and you're gonna have to
learn to deal with that emotion
right and now we kind of live in a
society which
doesn't believe in people dealing with
any emotions and it's sort of like you
know
we over prescribe for everything right
so it's like you know now you have the
kids
notoriously that are hyper six-year-olds
like six years are supposed to be hyper
and jumping off
put them on ritalin put them on my eye
roll your kid won't focus on math it's
like because he literally wants to be
outside
screaming and jumping from the monkey
bars and like you know jumping off of a
tire swing and instead you're telling
them to focus on
math like that's a normal thing and so i
i see what you're talking about
regarding like all of these things
before you get to the thing because now
i know those girls who took the xanax
and they're 30 and they're out of their
minds you know because every time they
feel an emotion
they put a pill they don't know how to
deal with regular anxiety you know
because they don't know that like you
have to figure out how to deal with
yeah a lot of the thing you know like
sugar will make it it's crazy if you cut
that out of the diet
i think these big tech companies don't
want to have any liability for self-harm
so when i was talking with jack dorsey
for instance on the joe rogan show
what did jack say he's like well there's
a lot of people who are prone to suicide
so we need to protect that group right
what is what is youtube saying right now
when it comes to their rules and all of
this stuff just make sure you tell
people to go to their own doctor right
now i
genuinely do believe joe rogan should
not be giving medical advice and you
should be going to your doctor and i'm
not giving anybody advice go to your
doctor
but they're worried that someone's gonna
do something they're gonna blame youtube
they're gonna blame twitter
and then they're going to have to pay
out for it i think it's cool to talk
about like all all the kovitz stuff is
like one thing but then the
the talking about like the medical
industry is a whole other
it's very important yeah yeah could you
imagine
what's going to happen to all the bernie
sanders supporters who want universal
health care
when they start making videos
complaining about the big pharmaceutical
industries the cost of health care
their concerns about how drugs are given
out to make money instead of actually
curing diseases
oh youtube's going to ban all of those
bernie america is like that i mean
especially you know obviously i'm
married to a brit and
when you go overseas or you go to europe
and you see the relationship that they
have it's just
we over prescribe our idea is to not
treat anything you know to diagnose it
before you even understand it and give
somebody a pill right and so like
obviously
the fact that i was able i knew why i
was sad you know what i mean i knew why
i was sad it wasn't like i was just like
woke up broke down crying and didn't
know why then you said okay maybe
there's some you know chemical imbalance
and
increasingly we're getting people that
don't don't even understand themselves
before they're kind of put onto
the big pharma track which is a pill to
manage everything in life and then when
when they don't have that pill and they
feel an emotion coming up like their
their thing is how do i get rid of it
how do i make it go away when you have
left you had that conversation with zoey
what was your life the whole experience
for the next few like how did you kind
of it's still sucking i was still sad
there you go i was still sad i threw all
the pills out because it just made so
much logical sense what she said and i
thank god because i'm like i don't know
what would happen if i just was like
taking xanax all the time
but i i had that mentality of i
recognize i'm sad
because this thing happened and i now
i'm
able to deal with sadness because i know
what it feels like
if i you have anxiety oh my god i'm
excited i have to take a pill i gotta
feel why are you anxious
because i have finals okay well then you
know why you're
you're anxious so you gotta figure out
how to channel that because it's not
healthy to keep thinking that you just
take something to make
human emotions go away now of course
there's a line where like okay and then
you say like you just brought up
what about the kid who's gonna like
actually just kill himself right well
what about that's different actual
chemical imbalance and that's exactly
medication and that's what zoe said she
said if you said to me candace
i'm crying i don't know why yeah there
you go something's wrong right and that
exists
what if i said to you i have anxiety
because of the military-industrial
complex
i'd be like bro turn off youtube i don't
think there's i don't want to pill it
out but like
what's the solution yeah yeah i'm being
there's a real question by the way yeah
the solution is to talk to a
medical professional and ask always a
medical opinion and
if you're unhappy you get a second
opinion well it could be like a
psychiatrist
i mean i just want to treat the problem
your anxiety
yeah like i'm have anxiety because the
military industrial complex was built in
the i think the 40s to
be the world police and i'm concerned
you should you should you should talk
about it
um i don't think you should have anxiety
over that okay
i mean anxiety is a real thing you just
get anxious sometimes about whatever
it is i mean but people don't know what
was also really about is that
increasingly
people don't realize that that's a human
emotion that you're going to have to
learn to deal with you know in every
capacity and
unless it's crushing and overwhelming
and you like you can't like you know
i don't know again opinion talk to your
doctor but i'm just talking about a
personal space that happened to me and
it really shaped
my my mindset on those things i'm yeah
i'm not and i want to make sure this is
clear too
like i'm not just saying talk to your
doctor because youtube says it
i legit was like when joe rogan said
people shouldn't get the vaccine i was
like joe come on like
people shouldn't be asking a comedian or
a tv doctor for advice
yeah but it's not advice it's an opinion
right so why that's my thing is like why
can't joe have an opinion
like if you said like if i just said to
you like you know
teenagers shouldn't be taking xanax like
why is it suddenly like you're not a
doctor how dare you it's like dude it's
just an opinion like
now everyone's like too offended to hear
people's opinions like i have an opinion
when i was you know working with charlie
kirk charlie was running at one point 10
miles a day
right literally like a psychopath a
total psychopath everywhere we went we
were traveling five times a week he
would just grab his shoes and go
and i would say him over and over again
you really shouldn't run five ten miles
a day
i'm not a freaking pe teacher i'm not
like you know but i was like that's not
gonna be can't be good for your joints
and charlie had the opinion they should
do it you should be like normal you
should just be able to give your opinion
and then all of a sudden what happened
charlie hurt his back and charlie can't
run anymore so guess what
i didn't have to be a pe teacher and now
i always said him you know charlie hate
to say this but
i told you so told you so why can't joe
rogan have an opinion
there's a difference in having an
opinion and expressing it that's no
that's fine that's a good point
but with great power comes great
responsibility and so
they didn't ban joe for saying this joe
just came out i don't think
you know joe's response was listen to
fouchyam and eddie and i'm like no no no
no no
fauci is a tv doctor yeah so like i i i
we had we had someone on the show who
mentioned uh i don't know it was crowded
crowder mentioned this
uh he put out this video where he said
his wife uh went to the doctor and
because of her medical issues the doctor
said you are not a candidate for the
vaccine
and that's like a legitimate doctor
saying here are the here's the things
you need to understand about why you are
or aren't
you know you know should be doing this
fauci's the guy was on tv says everybody
should just go and get it it's like
stop stop they're gonna be people who
walk to a bar and get drunk and
and these guys don't know their medical
history and then what is is fouchy going
to be out responsible yeah but why but
why should joe rogan say that that's i i
don't i don't like this argument and i'm
gonna
say i disagree with you on this because
joe rogan is a podcaster
he's the guy who likes ufc he talks yes
he has a big following
so what why why why why aren't we
teaching people to better discern who
you should be getting information from
right why are we trying to make it seem
like now that he has a big platform
now everything he says like you know he
has to take you know everything
at the same time though and here's why
that also annoys me is because let
any of these hollywood celebrities be
like let your kids pick your gender
and we know obviously it can lead to
suicide people you know people
mutilating their bodies
young all of these things that are much
more complex we don't kill them
it's because they have an issue with
this particular instance of him sharing
his opinion do you mean ban them
yeah we ban them yeah exactly make them
go away but it's because of this
particular instance because it's
surrounding big pharma
there's a lot more sensitivities he
gives his opinion about a ton of stuff
i mean he could say do yoga he's talked
about medicine he's talking about
psychedelics
whatever he's a podcast let him have his
opinion about things but
joe rogan didn't get banned over him
telling that story like
what i mean is like people who go on
youtube and tell people to do something
they're like you should do this here's
what you should do i'm like nah
nah nah like you you like if you if
like dr fauci going on tv and telling
people to do yeah
there's gonna be people who look when
when donald trump mentioned
hydroxychloroquine
and then everyone started freaking out
what if people actually start eating
fish food like that one story which
turned out to be bunk i guess
what's the difference between dr fauci
saying the same thing so then you also
disagree with all the celebrities doing
the photos of them getting the shot in
the arms
absolutely well when they tell you to go
do something they do they they should
all
be saying ask your doctor if this and
they don't i know
yeah so it's like it's like joe rogan's
getting hit for what everybody is doing
but if it's on the other end of the
spectrum it's fine it's irresponsible
for a bunch of people to be sticking
their arms in
and being like get the vaccine you know
what i mean get the vaccines today did
what i did today got the shot it's
equally as
irresponsible in my opinion raise
smarter
human beings okay if you're so dumb that
you are that you think that every one of
your life decisions should be informed
by joe rogan
okay you've got a lot bigger and no but
the same time to anybody right but yeah
i mean that life is like medical
decisions right like anybody or you or
me like if you're so dumb that you think
that like everything you do should be
exactly what
tim does or what candace does or what
joe rogan has i'm throwing us all in the
same box here
like you know then you're you probably
shouldn't have the internet because
you're a very
malleable mind and like it's just not a
safe place for you to be like i mean you
need a safe space
i just i just mentioned how like earlier
i was like i picked wild berries and
then we cooked them we made wild berry
chicken it was amazing
like we cooked them down with some lemon
juice in it but um let one person do the
wrong wild berry and there you go
no i don't know the white ones one said
to make wild berries
remember the media was saying eat
cicadas yeah the whole time i'm like no
don't eat bugs off the ground they could
be
dirty there's a story about a dude who
ate like a slug on a dare and then got
paralyzed and my gosh
and you had a guy in leesburg virginia i
read that story it was crazy
the guy the slug yeah there was there's
a guy in leesburg virginia who was
filmed i think was by cnn going out and
picking cicadas off the wall and being
like i'm going to serve this to people i
always wondered how over the
thousands of human years of history how
we figured out what herbs are safe to
eat
it's because people died people ate all
the other ones yeah yeah that's exactly
right or even like you know
the trending kylie jenner lip the lip
challenge and now
tick-tock is dying because it's like
it's like a little at a certain point we
just have to ask people to be a little
smarter what's the kind
we have to stop putting there was the
lip challenge where people were
literally putting their bottles and
their lips in bottles and getting stuck
and having the emergency i mean there's
like a whole crazy thing of people doing
things because they find stuff on the
internet
and at the end of all these things they
always blame someone like kylie jenner
like joe rogan it's like no we just have
to raise
smarter people you have to be able to
discern especially with so much
information
like you you obviously are not following
joe rogan because you're like he's at
his doc if his name was doctor joe wrote
like dr
joe biden i think you know you're a
little responsible because you're
pretending to be a doctor right and like
people might take what you're saying
seriously but like joe has never
pretended he was a medical doctor
and no one who is a fan of his would say
he did
right no one is following his stuff so
they're trying to say he's irresponsible
but
i think that's a little just i think
that's a little um and it's just not
genuine to say that it's not
disingenuous
i think we do have a problem with people
just going online and then doing dumb
and now all of a sudden we're
responsible right it's like oh my god
like that's it and it's like that's not
fair to us that's not fair it's like
just be smarter you know like be smarter
if you're looking for information go see
your doctor i mean that's kind of common
sense if you're looking for medical
information go to your doctor
like i'm talking about my personal
experience about gardasil like does that
mean that every single person shouldn't
get garcia i don't know go pursue your
own information but don't say
what was irresponsible when candace
shared that story about gardasil because
she's on a doctor it's like no
dude like i'm telling you what happened
to me you just talked about your front
your tongue like it's
i'm just so tired for like now we're all
responsible for everybody else's it is
like
100 of double standard when a celebrity
can
tell someone to get medicated and then
youtube says you can't do that
youtube says if you recommend these
things it's against the rules and i'm
like
but they pick and choose like is it
responsible when lena dunham posts and
you know the whole fat positive movement
which makes me sick right
right and like literally the number one
killer forget covert 19 it's fat
literally the number one killer in
america is heart disease led
from over from obesity is it responsible
causes cancer causes every every bad ill
you know really comes from being
overweight
is it responsible when uh lena dunham
decides to put a post on instagram about
how much she loves her fat
they start hashtags about fat positivity
and all these women talk about and i'm
not talking about
a little extra curves i'm talking about
clinical obesity right there's a literal
clip if you go to
lena dunham's instagram page you can
pull it up and look at it of her writing
this whole long diatribe
about how happy she is to be fat and how
we need to do this so we need to
normalize fat
you're literally saying for people to
normalize things that is the number one
killer in america
do i do i hear her being canceled do i
hear her being banned or is she being
asked to issue a statement
oh but joe rogan it's like it's just
it's just yeah she was talking about
sugar and aspartame and high fructose
probably a lot more pushback oh but she
is right when you talk about clinical
obesity like i mean you have to see the
picture honestly i don't know if you
guys
during this thing pop up and throw
things up you have to see what i'm
talking about this image that she put up
it's
it's disgusting it really is and we've
gone from love yourself in any size
meaning like yeah i agree with that like
some girls are curvy some girls are
thinner like that's cool but now we're
talking about celebrating clinical
obesity and those people are never hell
responsible in fact it's the exact
opposite they're held up as
brave read the articles brave inspiring
so amazing
i don't think i put up that and you need
to show it you better what is it
it's from her instagram page and it's
her sitting recently yeah maybe like a
month ago but like i don't know that she
posts too much and i saw it and i was
like
any person who objectively knows about
health knows that this is a bad way to
program people
and have kids in the comments going this
is so brave it's so inspiring it's like
what is it inspiring you to do when
someone who obviously has clinical
obesity this isn't like she's a couple
of extra pounds it's clinical obesity
and you're celebrating it joe rogan
lena dunham hold on here's my point
here's my point i don't think lena
dunham should be going around telling
people to be unhealthy
and like giving them advice like you
should eat garbage food and be unhealthy
and not take care of yourself
and i don't i don't think people should
be recommending that people go do things
it's fine to have an opinion it's fine
to be like here's what i think here's
what happened to me
he says he he said in that clip joe said
you know if you ask
if you had asked me i would say no you
shouldn't do it if you're whatever age
he didn't say in a way as if he was some
great authority it was very much opinion
and he is an opinionator
i'm an opinionator you're an opinionated
right right what i mean is
when a celebrity posts a photo saying go
get the vaccine when fauci posts
goes on tv says everybody should go do
it i'm like no that's irresponsible go
talk to a doctor
because we had uh because you we have
the story from people like crowder
you have a story where people literally
say i went to my doctor my doctor said
no it's that's it's that simple and that
might be your case maybe it's right
you're pregnant yeah there's all sorts
of different things and yeah but at the
end of the day i think
we have to start having people be
responsible for like you know
thinking yeah yeah it kind of goes back
to the master slave or leader follower
conversation where like
if you want to be a teacher you might
maybe you shouldn't be or if you want to
be the president you're probably not cut
out for the job
if if you're in a position of leadership
like you are or like tim is big time
you guys are it's not like you want
everyone to fall on every word you say
but they're going to i want people to
think
and that's why when i'm doing like when
i do podcasts i'm encouraging like from
the beginning talking about aliens
my whole mission is to make people think
critically think critically about even
what i'm saying right
so that's my goal and i think that
that's the role that we play
as podcasters and commentators is that
we're taking the news and we're thinking
critically about how we digest that news
and i think that's kind of the role that
someone like joe rogan serves when he's
talking about all these different topics
it's just we're just thinking
and we can't make thinking and saying
what your opinion is
a crime how do you find critical well
these uh these
youtube channels these big tech
companies have
zero faith in the average person and
they think that
someone's going to watch beefs and butt
head and then go play frog baseball so
they better tell everybody you can't do
it if we travel down that path
and we have been then eventually you
just get rid of all media
and then your movies will be like in
that movie you mentioned of lying with a
guy sitting in a chair in a white
background just reading a piece of paper
about history anytime it'll be like
warning
this is a joke any time being honest
though the real it's not because they're
afraid people are going to harm
themselves it's because like i said
there's profit motives and right now
you know they're pretending they care
about the irresponsibility of what joe
said but in reality they just want
people to get the vaccine and that's
they don't want a parent well you say
that but they don't care about that
right because if somebody does get
injured from the vaccine
they don't care that people told you to
get it they care about you telling them
not to get it so it's actually it's it's
not because they care about being sued
or they care about people's help it's
because they their motive right now
across the board media and big tech is
to make people get the vaccines and the
dna of their posit
of their um policies now facebook
literally has an
you cannot say anything even if it's
true that creates vaccine hesitancy
right so that's not them caring about us
it's not like they're just like oh we
don't want to get sued
because then why can't they be sued if
someone does get the vaccine and gets
injured
there's a law that was i guess it's uh
um
if you get injured you can't sue these
companies yeah yeah they're removed from
liability so it's not and like i said
follow always follow the money they're
getting billions and billions and
billions of dollars
um from big pharma and so i mean i'm i'm
very aware that we're talking about you
know
when we were even talking about what joe
rogan says is because he has too big of
a platform for him to even introduce
that perspective at
all um it steps on the toes of important
and powerful people
and in my opinion we should always be
able to think critically about
everything well let's go to super chats
and we'll see what the audience has to
say if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe
and um it's probably more important than
ever that you go to timcast.com and
become a member because
this whole conversation was definitely
you know icarus flying close to the sun
maybe the wax wings will melt and we
will fall but then you'll find us at
timcast.com
worst case scenario is if we get a
strike we get taken off the air for a
week
but it affects literally all of the our
youtube channels everyone that you are
connected to
that i that i run personally with me
talking on it i i guess i could like
yeah that's it so it's like all my
channels are it's for a week and then we
just do the website so we'll be at
timcast.com but uh let's let's
let's read some of these uh super chats
that we got going on i hope they're
being nice
sometimes they're mean it's a good
conversation i mean this would be nice
to me guys
falcon laser says tim cast and the daily
wire need to team up to produce a movie
about ufos
yes okay i'd be in i don't know if like
the rest of the
i i pitched them all the time on things
we should do like i was like
i'm bringing i'm bringing the spice in
daily wire let me tell you in the movie
you should play the president
yeah because that way we're virtue
signaling because we have a black female
president absolutely and never actually
falls really high and it's all about
being president
that's amazing uh let's see what is this
alexander scarpetti says omg candace
owens i love you what a great patriot i
can't wait to see
her as president thank you so much
woot do for you says mcafee ain't dead
he just went home
i saw a message there like mcafee did
not uninstall himself
[Laughter]
that's really funny
orion galaxy says candace you'll always
be mcqueen
thank you so much there you go egg and
spoonracer says aliens refuse to make
first contact until we agree to use
their correct pronouns
that's all it is can we pronounce those
yeah yeah probably whatever their
pronouns are
z zeros m what if that was really like
the big thing is that
they're gearing up for these pronouns
because the aliens have like 12 genders
yeah it's like high-pitched frequency
but we don't know how to make
that noise with our bodies yet yeah
daniel gao says candace and tim two of
my absolutely favorite people
you both have inspired me i'm currently
reading anything i can by thomas sowell
and will be starting my own podcast on
the news from a biblical perspective
this fall thank you for your examples
yeah thank you very good thomas soul man
you can you read one thomas soul book
you will never come back that dude is a
genius
he's just his book smacked me into a
different reality which one
um the first one i read was race and
economics
economics and race might be like that's
incredible it just destroys every race
argument because he is like
hi america let's look at these global
arguments let's globalize the arguments
that you're having in america
and you know starts from the very
beginning like versus like the whole
fallacy of believing that because you're
a minority sometimes some higher
disadvantage he's like that's
been disproven all across the world at
every
every facet of society that actually
minorities tend to get ahead
and he just kind of starts there right
oh is that because they're more cohesive
yeah well it's just like in every
society
i mean you'd be shocked you know it at
every emp and every
empire who was controlling the banks and
he just goes and just
obliterates any of the race arguments
that we're having today and you realize
it's all built upon a house of cards
and um people just know very little
about everything i mean even like
slavery
slavery wasn't predicated on race um the
truth is is that
black americans i mean blah blah blah is
black africans were brought over here
um because we were immune to
yellow fever which the indian native
americans had so we were just a better
breed
better stock of um slaves to have and
slavery obviously
everywhere in the world the romans would
enslave anybody yeah egyptians weren't
slaving i mean slavery started with the
with
muslims um and so he just kind of just
takes you all through history and you're
like
wow everything i learned in school was a
lie you know you know whose story i
really really loved was herman cain's
i love him i watched that documentary
uncle tom yeah i was in it
yeah yeah it was it was fantastic yeah
herman cain man what what an amazing
story
all of them i mean yeah clarence thomas
i mean uh shelby steele it's
their their stories i read their books
because these people that are
so castigated in the media and they have
lived through so much
i mean condoleezza rice they grew up in
actual segregation and they're called
racists
and people are just so polluted and so
dumb really that they just accept that
well clarence thomas obviously like
grew up in your interrogation he just
wants more of it now it's like come on
man it's so easy to believe what you're
told what i'm told
it's it's also kind of easy to question
everything so like there's a balance
okay sometimes you just gotta trust
sometimes vanessa
stuller says it is completely insane
that candace owens is having a
conversation with ian regarding
electricity and has kept him quiet for
more than
two minutes i am in complete awe candace
you are awesome
are you gonna install the neural net
after they work out the kinks
yeah 100 nice let's do it i hope i hope
that the first half an hour of the show
is the most confusing thing to the
political
journalists what is happening how do we
smear candace for her opinions on
electricity and thomas edison
yeah they'll figure it out do you
meditate i don't actually but i love the
bikram yoga
oh yeah i guess that's kind of a moving
meditation yeah
b anderson says didn't nikola tesla
invent a way to give people free energy
then get
squashed by big money yeah i mean
there's a lot of conspiracy theories out
about him being killed
um and so the answer is yes he was
working on sending electricity
through the ground but people were kind
of afraid they're like what if it
well they started a big uh you know the
propaganda the newspapers you know jd
rockefeller got out and started saying a
bunch of stuff about nikola tesla and
how
it was gonna if if his circuit the way
that he was going to circuit it was
different
if that got out things would blow up
people would die so it was always fear
has always been used as a tactic to
control the masses and into making
decisions and like blackout like nassim
harriman is a quantum physicist of the
day he's working on how to get energy
out of the vacuum
but like where is that in the media like
they don't want to slander the guy they
just want
you do not know who nasa is but look up
nassem he's great
william s says ian is the fox mulder of
our generation
please create the crossland files i want
to believe in graphene
this is what's that question everything
is too extreme let's find a balance
just think you know it's not even like
you have to question it but like i just
think
think right like oh like i said like a
thought is does jeff bezos really want
to help me turn my lights on that's a
thought
you know and like look at the past and
think
why why was the bible written as it was
let's try and figure out if that was
real life and this is a book written
about it
what was it really that so in reference
to that
little green men thing with mark millie
aaron j says millie is talking about
hybrid warfare and little green men in
the strategic way
to refer to soldiers that are
non-attributable to specific countries
but little green men yeah like a weird
way to say it's like yeah this is
doesn't it
diy green and why not just say soldiers
well i was thinking it was homoflorences
those old hominids that got extinct what
if they found advanced technology and
went underground and now they're flying
around
there's a conspiracy theory that a
species of dinosaur
lived in caves when the meteor hit and
went deep into mine in like
cave systems and then evolved to become
super intelligent but they can't go to
the surface because the sunlight would
burn them
so they live in giant underground cities
and there's a fun
underneath the denver international
airport there is yeah talk about sweden
okay
i don't know about the dinosaur part but
let me tell you
the denver airport like all the
questions around denver airport are
legitimately
interesting and you should look them up
basically there was just no reason to
have the airport built
they did build all this entire
underground system and they just didn't
use it like i mean just like it's
incredible like actually
i don't even know what the conspiracy
this conspiracy theory is but there's a
lot of question marks about the building
of the denver airport and now every time
i'm there i'm like
whoa i am from colorado and i have heard
my understanding is that there's a heavy
influence of the military colorado's
such a heavily military state and i'm
willing to bet that it's in some way
connected to cheyenne mountain
i've heard that there's a direct line
from dia to cheyenne there's definitely
something
underneath denver airport now i don't
know about dinosaurs that can't put
their head up
but there's definitely like they just
like built all this up and said oh never
mind we can't use it and they
i mean everything surrounding the
permits build it was just weird shady
i've heard like a conspiracy that it's
because like the wealthiest people if
they ever need to get out that's where
they would go
because it's kind of like in the middle
of like yeah um but i don't know if
that's true but there is interesting
facts about the building of a denver
airport that are if you
have just like like to bend your brain a
bit that's a fun one to look at super
fun
all right joshua all britain says
candace please be trump's vp
so my beloved florida doesn't lose
desantis or you can come replace him as
florida's governor and he can be vp i'm
good with either
well i'm i don't live in florida so i
don't think i can become governor but i
agree with you very much that desantis
should never run as vp i mean that would
be such a waste of desantis and
you know i was saying before we went
live on this that the santa
single-handedly ended
um the pandemic totalitarianism
by keeping florida a free state um and
the the measures that he took made it
impossible for other states to keep
you know pursuing their lockdowns
because he proved that the lockdowns
weren't necessarily
helping in terms of spreading i mean in
terms of stopping this part of the virus
so there were so many things that he did
he has been a phenomenal
phenomenal governor um and i know i
can't sing his praises enough and i
totally agree that people are asking for
him to run with trump i'm just like you
are missing the forest for the trees on
that one what if he runs as president
if he went as president i mean he would
i personally think that trump's going to
run again
in 2024 um but if he ran as president i
would very much support
governor desantis he's been great
president yes just ronda sanders in that
point i kept thinking it was rhonda
i was like who's this ronda guy he's
been amazing
he's been amazing jb says how typical
a talk for money grifter helping another
talk for money grifter stay relevant
thank you it took like three years for
me to finally figure out what grifter
meant
my husband thought it was so funny like
what's grifting like rifter what is it
exactly and then so now
my husband always say to each other like
for anything like griffith's got a grift
griffin's got a grift
yeah griffith i guess it's like they're
saying you're inauthentic and you're
just saying things for money
yeah the money would really be there if
i wanted to make money being a black
liberal is the way to go just so we're
clear right like just so we're very
clear like the idea that somehow it's
easier to make money as a black
conservative than as a black liberal
they
they would be handing me accolades like
could you imagine me as the black
liberal
like they would i would be like they
would have me giving oscar speeches
like i would be everywhere huge mss
non-stop
oh my god i've got my own show on cnn
msnbc everything
imagine if kanye came out with a big
message about supporting hillary clinton
yeah what would they have said about
he's the smartest most brilliant i mean
it's such a joke
the the concept that to make the money
the quick buck you go and become a black
conservative oh okay cool
all the media is against you that's the
easiest route to go that's the funniest
thing there's like a scripting i said
yeah like
why would you want to go against the
machine yeah the machine will
put you up it's the machine like so it's
just again people don't like to think so
let me let me risk my livelihood
and and everything i mean like yeah your
everything is wrist when you come out
and you speak out as a black
conservative
what's being risked by these socialist
youtubers who are like i agree with
amazon.com and walmart.com my opinions
are not controversial in any way
i'm like you risk nothing and they may
and they get propped up by youtube
algorithms put them at the top every
time you search them it's like follow
this celebrity who's saying every single
thing that we agree with
exactly they can come out and they can
give medical advice and it's fine yeah
no questions i love that dr bill gates
has given so much advice on
what we should do i love the meme where
it was like
joe rogan and bill gates both gave
medical advice and bill gates was
propped up and championed by the media
and joe rogan was
like insulted and and they criticized
him right here's my opinion
my opinion is we shouldn't listen to
either of their opinions
we should listen to them because we're
like okay i want to follow this guy i
want to follow this
guy but they are equally as legitimate
so it's like i didn't spaz out and say
like okay bill gates should not be
allowed to even give his opinion
so why are people spazzing out joe rogan
gives his opinions interesting ability
to be able to listen to somebody but not
let it rewrite your brain right that's a
talent
that's my that's my talent i listen to
people and doesn't rewrite
my brain that is my superpower all right
i always thought i wanted to be mystique
but
this is yeah what's mystique's
superpower hate when people say this
she shape changes not a single person at
the daily wire i knew who mystique was
like i never even heard of her i hate to
say this i shouldn't be giving out daily
wire dirty secrets but like not a single
one not andrew clavin
not michael knowles not ben shapiro
nobody
knew who mystique was and it hurt my
heart cause i'm such a big x-men fan
yeah
like i'm an x-men dweeb and i was like
but not not jennifer lawrence she ruined
mystique
you know i wonder rebecca remained
stamos as mystique
wow when when mystique is like she's
naked right when she shapeshifts and
then she's in clothes
is that clothes like her skin you know
what i mean like if you were to cut the
clothing with the clothing bleed that's
such
an interesting question no i think the
second you cut it then she turns back
into the lizard
the lizard oh she's kind of whatever
blue skin she's scaly
yeah all right marty uh toro jr says tim
if you fire subsonic rounds through a
sound suppressor it is as quiet as a
sneeze i am active duty military
and i have footage of this i've seen
footage
of like super quiet suppressed rounds
like subsonic
but it's not like pew pew pew i've not
seen that maybe i'm wrong
have you not seen a james bond film i
just can't understand i keep saying i
have it's just not in real life what do
you mean it's not real life what do you
say
is this not real life james bond is not
real life are you saying mystique
doesn't exist
are you not real you really are
conspiracy theorists
there's no mystique there's no magneto
wow unacceptable
elizabeth carmela comedian says dude my
psychic is on point
i was just thinking earlier today when
candace owens was going to make her way
to tim cast and boom here she is
can she tell us more psychic stuff yeah
give me the lottery yeah come on gay
something
i want to win half a billion dollars in
the retirement exactly all i get from
your psycabilities is i'm on tim cass i
want to be a billionaire
yeah give us a like psychic premonitions
no i don't have psychic premonitions
i like to communicate with people with
your thoughts i wish i could
but no i don't have any powers you can
yeah
kev says ian this is for you because you
rock please show mr pool the videos
he'll be surprised
i've been heavy into pew pews for 35
years and even i'm learning something
new every week ps
original voltron was 15 vehicles that
made one mech
what i thought it was five wow is he
talking about the suppressor videos
yeah something like that i've never seen
it yeah
mike west says uh well i can't read that
youtube will ban me sorry dude
um eric a says tim i'm surprised you
missed this story amazon donated
hundreds of copies of eber max kennedy
book to virginia public school
turns out they are teaching critical
race theory and then they go uber max
kennedy's not a critical race theorist
he's just a guy who writes ideology that
was inspired by
critical race theory and is adopting
those ideologies now go ask any of those
children who plato was who aristotle was
who socrates was they have no idea
yeah it's all about creating the modern
far left
person that just listened to the
government who sees the problems
everywhere except for where it is which
is the fact that you know government is
growing itself exponentially
and they're just creating people that
will plug themselves into government and
and
you know to get a little deeper on that
the entire concept of why they're making
kids stupid right
and so imagine being a kid you you go
through the school system you then go
and you get your
bachelor's degree then you'll get your
master's degree and you get your
master's degree in something that's
literally stupid like you can get a
master's degree in gender studies so
she's just like
that's really stupid it's a lot of money
to spend on such stupidity and then
demand the government pay it back
and then you cut out of school you've
got all these student loans and you
realize you can't get a job because it
turns out that nobody needs
the person to tell them 27 000 genders
but the kid that you went to high school
with
that didn't go to college and can fix an
ac is making a ton of money
well that instantly creates a very angry
angry citizen and they're mad at this
system they're mad at something
and they have to channel that anger
somewhere because they either can become
a professor or they become failures and
if you want to know why so many of these
antifa types who are blowing up you know
police
vehicles um are college-educated it's
because they're angry they're angry
because they they're convinced of their
own intelligence right because i've gone
there's many degrees they're going to
degree in this regular degree in
they're passionately stupid midwifes
yeah i like that ralph nesbit says ian
it was battle of the planets the 70s
power rangers nice
is that that was the first one i guess
so yeah the raptors town says i had a
sans
samsung galaxy s8 for years and was
forced to upgrade after t-mobile bought
out sprint
the official reason was because it was
outdated coincidence i think not
no planned obsolescence yeah that's
concerning
yeah that's corruption in capitalism
capitalism isn't supposed to be you
invent a libel that lasts forever and
you become rich and everyone celebrates
the new innovation
instead we get failing light bulbs and
then everyone's got to buy a new one
every week
baby i heard there's a move to uh to
make right of repair
legal have you guys heard about this
right to repair right to repair which
means that like
you have the right to get all the parts
for this whereas before it's the
proprietary you have to send it back to
the company and they'll fix it for you
and send it back oh wow
decentralizing repair
it's actually interesting charlie alpha
says retired military pilot and the
scariest thing i ever did
start a trucking company between jobs
independence is scary but so rewarding
we must have courage as evil triumphs if
good men do nothing
that's exactly right and so true it's
scary take risks but
big risks equal big rewards and by the
way you're allowed to fail
people are very scared to fail i've
failed so much in my life and i
what happens when you fail and you get
back on you know the uh the figurative
horse the figurative bike is that then
you're
you develop more of immunity of like oh
sometimes you try things they don't work
out
and now society is built around people
being too afraid to fail
and like failure is good that's how you
learn i mean virtually every person that
really made it in life failed at some
point
before yep and but now they don't want
they don't want kids thinking like they
just go to college you get a degree or
else you're going to be a failure
and actually you know you're going to be
a failure if you don't try to do things
outside of the
box establishment box a non-failure
isn't a success
necessarily you can be a non-failure and
still not succeed a d minus isn't going
to make you a success
you likely will not succeed unless
you've had failures yeah how
unless you're the rare lucky person who
went to a in a bottle lottery ticket
right right it's so true so true robert
adams says this is the problem in living
in a world with too many lawyers making
us believe
opinions should be sued no personal
responsibility yeah that is
i agree with that yeah everybody's gonna
sue them just tried to sue me over an
opinion
really can you talk about it yeah it was
the whole kimberly classic thing that
happened
me and her got into like a whole tiff
online and like i started looking into
her fec files like the new scam right
now like like probably just so not aware
of it like there's
people that are pretending to run for
office in dishes they know they can't
win and they just raise a ton of money
and keep running and running and running
and i just sort of looked into this and
like looked at her fec filings and all
this money was going off to defunct
businesses and like defunct
i just exposed it all and exposed the
fact that she used to be a stripper
which nobody knew
you know who popped up and i was just
like you know in my opinion like when i
think of a strip club i think of money
laundering that's what made me go check
her fec filings
and i exposed it all and then like she
had her lawyer try to get me to take
down the video by being like
you're like your opinion that she used
to you know saying that she was
like the weirdest thing they're like the
mad damn at the strip club and i'm like
they were trying to make it seem like i
meant like a human trafficker madam and
i didn't mean i meant like her husband
was the manager of the strip club and
like she
got people to strip there and they like
did this whole thing and i was like nope
sorry if you're going to sue me go for
it like people have a right to the truth
you don't even care about this one
sentence you're just trying to get the
whole fec filing scene taken down
but better or worse a lot of these
opinion things just never make it past
motion
like the motion to dismiss it just
they're gone yeah no it's but it's like
the new thing is like people
yeah it's the same people that say they
believe in free speech that will try to
shut it down you know to protect
themselves and their
grift as i learned to learn this new
world this new word too i mean the same
stuff with the nicole arbor stuff she
was trying to like oh have a lawyer said
it was like send it
like you know somebody talking about
what you're doing and now it's the way
they protect themselves is everyone
thinks you're free when you send a legal
letter and it's like the truth is the
truth that is that is
you're fighting with nicole arbor as
well yeah i got into a whole big thing
with her she's i mean talk about the
ultimate like grifter
like i mean like just pretending to be
conservative once liberals had her
you know figured out and i you know and
so she
kind of rebranded as a trump supporter
nobody really looked into her and there
was a whole history of youtubers like i
don't
follow like i was saying to you like too
much on youtube but i then did follow
that there was a lot of men speaking up
and saying like these crazy things
happened with her but then she sent a
legal letter to get them to take the
videos down and like
crazy stuff and i was just like nah
nothing i hate more
let me tell you talk about things i'm
passionate against then the me too type
women
who like every time a man says anything
then they do like they're like
i was scared for my life and like like
that turned me into a dragon because
men are not able to defend themselves
right now
and women know that and she did the
dirtiest thing
ever to ryan upchurch she was like a
country rap star
and like literally he had to hand in his
guns
like because she wanted a video taken
down she wanted a video taken down and
so the way that she thought to do it was
to file an emergency injection junction
to get him to take down the video and so
for those who don't know an emergency
injunction like i saw the video that he
did
and it was shocking because it proved
like how much of a liar she was right
so his video goes up he like is you know
it's like boys girls tiff whatever he's
showing the time when she's showing that
like everything she said was a lie
and so it was so damaging to her career
that she wanted to turn down she went to
a domestic violence clinic he never hit
her nothing
and said like what do i do and they said
you can file an emergency injunction and
then he'll
until the judge can look at the case
he'll have to take down the video
they'll take his guns like all of this
stuff she did this
right and like so he had to take on
video they took his guns all the stuff
now it's been resolved and the judge
wrote back a thing being like she has a
credibility issue he looked into it
but she still got what she wanted the
video was taken down and he got his guns
back and all that stuff and like so i
used my platform to defend him like i
didn't know him
but i just hate seeing men being
pigeonholed
you know it's just like it's what's
going on with men right now it's just
women are like
really just taking advantage of being
crazy and you know who it hurts when you
do stuff like that real domestic
violence
um that's everybody's country it hurts
the country but it really especially
women
that have legitimate domestic violence
claims like when you start using this
as a way to i hate this guy so i'm gonna
say oh you know it's abusive like what
you know
tim did to me like you know he offered
me a slushie he's got a slushy machine
downstairs
it's pretty good but this is it's a new
culture of that too and me too
and i talk a lot about toxic feminism
and that's my second book is on that
and there's a lot of that now going
around yeah
all right sidekick says i think aliens
won't deal with us until there's a
unified world one language one currency
one leader etc
could explain the power struggles these
days i said that the last time i was on
the joe rogan podcast i was like
we're never going to meet the aliens
because the galactic federation doesn't
want to deal with a bunch of different
countries we need one unified planet to
join the federation
and joe said i don't think there's a
galactic federation
you got him i know i was kidding
i think that we could be unified with a
d with a lot of leaders and a lot of
currencies like a decentralized union
all right let's see what we got assassin
says candace is an honest soul
thank you i appreciate that i try to be
um
i think a lot of times my honesty gets
me in trouble but it's it's the only
thing i know
and i always say there's a kanye line
speaks to my soul he says in one of his
songs i suffer from realness
and i feel that lying i suffer from it
i'm like i gotta say i gotta say it so
nobody's saying it so i have to say it
my meditation is so
awesome because you have no thoughts you
can like choose one
i'm naturally a fighter and i just i
hate dishonesty and i just see it
everywhere and it's like you know i'm
fighting facebook fact checkers i'm
obviously in lawsuit with them like
taking you know these women that do the
false accusing women like but it all
matters to me because it's just like i
just want the society to be better for
my son to grow up in
like and all of this is a threat to my
son like you know like the society that
we
we got to have childhoods and make
mistakes even like the cancer culture of
like he tweeted that
he was 13 years old like i speak out
against everything um
because i just want the world to be
better were you like that when you were
little or yeah
i got did you get pushed around when you
were a kid like bullied and stuff no i
was i i was like
i was the no-nonsense toddler like
telling adults what was up like you are
trying to manipulate me
you know i was like no my dad and mom
used to have to close the door and laugh
because i would like demand a further
conversation i hated manipulation so
like they'd be like
don't do this santa's not going to come
and i'd be like well can you tell santa
i said not to come like
wow then i don't want his presence i
want an explanation for why i have to do
this
all right dlon smythe says youtube quote
when you send a message here people will
be able to see that you subscribe
that's a mafia level threat actually
it's this really cool thing apparently
you can make it so that if you want to
chat you gotta be a subscriber
boom that's it you just gotta click a
little button that works
because there's a lot of spam bots that
come in they don't subscribe they just
post stupid things about getting rich
quick or whatever oh i thought it was a
member
just a subscriber oh yeah that's smart
it's a great way to get the trolls out
that's really smart
super simple the regular person can just
click the button and you should
subscribe and like this video
all right jk nguyen says have any of you
heard about energy companies in texas
changing people's thermostats in their
homes
tech automation is like security higher
security less convenient higher
convenience less
secure this i understand to be a true
story but it's something they
they signed up for so you can sign up to
get a discount
and they have smart thermostats
so the company can set your thermostat
for you and then you save money
it's like a cheaper bill or something no
i haven't heard of that well fun fact uh
speaking about the green lobby and all
these people that are like climate
change blah blah do you know
um i like i know a people that work in
the industry conservatives are actually
the people that use the most clean
energy
oh really yeah uh so they they talk
about it but they don't commit to it so
they're not the ones that are driving
around the teslas and so i thought it
was very interesting when they told me
that they said yeah if
you're they're in sales and obviously so
they have like all the data and they are
much more likely going to a republican
and selling it
like my husband and i are going to do
like a kind of a half
um we're looking like a little bit solar
like half solar like not completely rely
on solar and he's like and i said some
people i think that's unusual and he
said nope
anybody on the industry knows that the
left is the app about it and the
conservatives commit to it
think about this big cities tons of
pollution
big cities police problems it's all the
democrat people who live there who
complain about this where do
conservatives live they live in rural
areas they tend to
conservative so people in rural areas
tend to have their own gardens their own
food have chickens
tend to chop their own wood tend to i
should say so
you're more likely going to find
environmentally conscious conservatives
than liberals but i will say perhaps you
will find most liberals claiming to be
environmental that's what they're saying
they yap it but they don't actually talk
but they don't actually walk the walk
they talk the talk they don't walk the
wall conservatives walk the walk and
don't talk the talk
which is like and i was just like what
he's like i can send you tons of data on
it like it's like
one of the big media like propaganda
efforts to make you think that because
they talk about it
they're living their life like that and
they just don't yeah when there's a
problem people will be like that's a
problem this but when anything's working
properly you don't point it out
necessarily
right daniel bundrick says if ian's
beauty filter video mentioned yesterday
gets more views than cnn's primetime
viewership i'll double this
super chat it's it's really really funny
like
the primetime viewership and the key
demo for cnn msnbc on weekends is like
50 to 60k yeah i know it's like very
easy that's not very it's not a hard
feat i mean like brian stelter jake
tapper like nobody what i get more views
just i could do one instagram video
right now and i get more videos like
nobody which should really tell you
where the society
is at they know it's propaganda there's
hundreds anymore you know you know they
sacrificed
i i used to have cnn running i turned it
i'd be working and i've seen it on the
background because it'd be like you know
a
storm would hit maybe there's a storm in
atlanta and uh then one day i realized
they were just talking about trump
non-stop non-stop it was like they they
eventually stopped doing any real
reporting veritas exposed this when they
had a
attack a technical director of some sort
somebody said
we used to go on the ground and do
reporting now we just do panels about
trump
so i turned it off so i was never a big
fan of cnn but i would leave it on
because at least i talk about news
i started talking about trump 24 7. i
turned it off i've never looked back
yeah they decided to chase the
anti-trump audience
and now that trump is gone they have no
audience left right
exactly right it's it's crazy that ian
we can make a video where it's like ian
talking about space chimps or something
yeah and it'll be cnn primetime
viewership yeah
the real news i'm looking forward to
space chimps man yeah
space chests the first animal in space
was a chimp from earth
or was it a monkey or something that the
russians fired off into
into space didn't make it didn't survive
it all right we'll do
uh we'll just do a couple more the prick
says youtube won't let me comment in
comment section says it's because i
subbed to this channel while watching a
video made for kids
what that's weird weird all right turk
longwell says damn
is candace standing up for everything
and everyone not the best thing ever
holy shoot candace is amazing please
keep it up candace thank you
thank you thank you very much right on
well absolutely thanks for hanging out
yeah
this has been a blast we're going to
have a bonus segment up at timcast.com
so make sure you like this video
subscribe to this channel
go to timcast.com become a member and
that's where we're going to say we're
all we're going to do is we're going to
press record
and then say just a stream of things
youtube bans you for
that's the point of the website yes uh
you can follow the show on facebook and
instagram
cast irl you can follow me personally at
tim cast did you want to shout anything
out i think everybody knows who you are
oh yeah uh join parlor my husband's a
ceo
um i do have a twitter unbeknownst to
ian if you can follow me there i found
out yeah he
found out and we're very proud of him
we've made a long long two hours for him
to find that out
and yeah buy my book blackout because
i'm so close to passing
half a million copies wow yeah so i need
to sell
20 000 more copies to pass half a
million copies and i want to celebrate
half a million copies
so for that reason it's also a really
good book and i actually wrote it i
didn't use a ghostwriter
which nobody does in politics it's
actually written by me read by me so buy
it just so
i can get this little acolot in my head
they don't send me anything but it just
means something to me where's the best
place people can get blackout
i hate to say amazon but
simoneschester.com and you can get it
from amazon you get anywhere target is
where people are picking them up like
hotcakes and playing the blackout game
which is where you find my book and you
black out somebody else like chrissy
teigen
um see i'm fighting every war
[Laughter]
yeah i'm i just wish we'd talk more
about lasers and psychedelics
and um monsters from space or something
yeah but maybe we'll get it out later
next time make a movie about it yeah
i'm ian crossland thank you for coming
and you can find me at ian crossland uh
dot net and at ian cross on all social
media
i love you i am so glad we were able to
have this genre busting conversation
with the spice queen of the daily wire
this has been a ton of fun and i'm
really looking forward to a bonus
segment you guys need to sign up for the
site for sure
and you guys are more than welcome to
follow me on twitter
at sourpatchlids as i'm attempting to
outstrip
sourpatch kids and followers
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you